[Musique]
Éric Crocrel, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bien sûr,
Éric Coqel euh né le 30 décembre 58 à
Courbeois, donc 65 ans, euh
engagé depuis l'âge de 14 ans euh
politiquement, je veux dire, j'étais à
Nard, j'étais autonome, j'étais Trotsky,
cétait la LCR,
j'étais avec Chevinement au début des
années 2000, j'ai créé un petit
mouvement qui s'appelle le mouvement
pour une alternative républicaine et
sociale de gauche républicaine
antilibérale.
J'ai cofondé le parti de gauche avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
J'ai été conseiller, j'ai été le
coordinateur de ce parti. J'étais
conseiller régional Île-de-Fance à
partir 2010 et puis élu député de Sensin
la circonscription Saint-Toin épinet ils
saint Saint euh en 2017 réélu depuis et
je suis président de la commission des
finances de l'Assemblée nationale et je
suis bien sûr France insoumise.
Vous avez travaillé avant d'être
politique, vous faisiez quoi ?
Bah en fait
euh pour être clair, je ne vis entre
guillemets de la politique, j'aime pas
trop cette expression. Enfin, j'ai j'ai
un mandat d'élu qui me permet de de
vivre de la politique que depuis 2017.
Donc, j'ai toujours travaillé. Euh
qu'est-ce principalement, qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait à partir de 89 ? J'ai
travaillé dans le domaine de la voile,
des courses de bateau. J'étais un des
unorganisateurs du premier vent des
globes et puis je me suis occupé de
marins, pas mal de marins assez
célèbres. Isabelle Aissier, Michel des
Joyaux, l'équipe de France de Voile
Olympique euh avec une petite boîte que
je dirigeais et puis auparavant j'ai
fait plein de boulot divers. C'est
failli. Moi j'ai j'ai passé mon bac en
étudiant Libe à 23 ans parce que je je
bossais en même temps. Fais des études
d'histoire et puis voilà qui m'a amené à
la voile parce que la mer est aussi ma
passion.
Ce soir l'interview on l' fait
j'ai toujours bossé en fait. Ce soir
l'interview on l'a fait en mode pétole
ou on sort l'espi ?
On se tuto, on se voit comme tu veux.
On va se tutoer sera plus simple.
Écoute, comme tu veux, les deux me vont
en fait.
Alors, on va envoyer du bois. Alors,
président de la commission des finances,
Ouais.
Il se passe quoi ? On nous a masqué les
choses, on a enjolivé les choses, on a
essayé de protéger la note de la France,
on a essayé de protéger les élections
européennes. On était dans le déni, pas
dans le déni.
Écoute, comme tu le sais, j'ai j'ai je
lance une commission d'enquête en tant
que président de la commission des
finances qui commence la semaine
prochaine avec les fonctionnaires de Ber
après il y aura Bruno Lemè puis on va
interviewer un peu tout le monde. On
aurait bien fait Macron, on n pas le
droit malheureusement mais on va aller
jusqu'à Colère je pense par exemple à
l'Élysée pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe qui s'est passé. Il y a
trois trois en gros trois idées forces.
Il y a ceux qui pensent que c'est de la
dissimulation. on a dissimulé pour des
raisons politiques et autres. Ceux qui
pensent ce que dit par Bruno le maire,
c'est plutôt un problème de technicien,
tu vois. soit les mauvaises choses qui
ont été mises en mis en route, des
erreurs de fonctionnaires,
ceux qui pensent, je fais plutôt partie
de ces troisè écoles que c'est plutôt la
politique économique, l'offre de de la
politique de l'offre, de la
compétitivité
qui euh s'est planté et dont finalement
ceux qui la prôent depuis des années ont
tellement été aveuglés par leur
croyances dans cette politique que je
pense que ça a déteint au bout d'un
moment sur les fonctionnaires qui
étaient sous leurs ordres et que tout ça
amené des erreurs énormes en terme de
prévision de déficit, prévision de
croissance
et cetera et cetera qui explique
pourquoi on fait une commission
d'enquête à partir de la semaine
prochaine à l'Assemblée.
Et alors question, est-ce qu'un
président de commission d'enquête peut
s'exprimer dans les médias avant avant
la commission ?
Bien sûr, je suis un élu hein, donc je
suis pas un fonctionnaire. J'ai pas j'ai
pas je suis pas juge, pas fonctionnaire,
je suis un élu et au contraire, je pense
que je dois m'exprimer devant les
médias. Euh si je fais une commission
d'enquête, c'est pas pour un snacle
entre députés qui vont interroger des
gens qui leur ressemble. C'est pour que
les D'ailleurs, c'est public hein, les
commissions d'enquête sont publiques. À
partir la prochaine, elle commence le 3
donc
retransmise sur YouTube
absolument et sur le site de
l'Assemblée. Donc tout ça vous le verrez
en direct et c'est pour que les gens se
sachent. Voilà, on travaille pour le
peuple. Enfin, moi c'est comme ça en
tout cas que je conçois mon mandat. Donc
euh
intérêt, je voulais juste des choses une
commission d'enquête. L'intérêt c'est
que les gens qui témoignent témoignent
sous sermon et si il ment après c'est du
pénal. Voilà donc c'est pour ça que
c'est bien une commission d'enquête.
Qu'est-ce qui risque d'ailleurs au pénal
s'il y a
trè je vais pas dire j'en sais rien mais
tu peux aller jusqu'à de la prison quoi.
Du du bracelet électronique et faire le
tour de France aussi. Voilà déjà, mais
enfin déjà une condamnation ça la fou
mal quoi.
Ouais, avec une peine d'inligibilité je
pense
par exemple. Ça peut être ça.
Revenons, revenons au fond du problème.
C'est un problème à 20 milliards, à 100
milliards, à 500 milliards. C'est
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce il y avait un trou
dans dans la voilure de combien là ?
Alors, en fait, il y avait surtout un
trou dans les prévisions. Alors, en
gros, euh le déficit euh si tu veux, on
est passé euh on est passé d'estimation
à un moment donné, on nous a vendu du 47
pour 2024.
Taux de croissance.
Taux de taux de croissance. Non,
déficit, pardon, déficit. Toi, tu me
fais dans le cro je vais venir à la
croissance après si tu veux. Le déficit,
on nous l'a vendu à 47 au début. Bon,
très franchement fin 2023 quand ils nous
ont mis ces chiffres sur la table, des
gens n'y croit. Enfin, quand je dis on,
c'est la plupart des des des
commissaires aux finances, on on était
pas d'accord, on disait il y a ça va pas
quoi. Ça ça ça c'est c'est pas possible
par rapport aux prévisions de croissance
justement. Mais enfin, on nous l'a donné
à 47. Euh quelques semaines après, euh
ça montait de mémoire, je te le dis.
Alors, excuse-moi si je me trompe de 0
points, mais en gros à 54, tu vois. Euh
et puis tout ça a terminé à plus de à
61. Voilà. Donc c'est une différence de
17. Euh donc c'est des différences de
centaines de milliards d'euros. Voilà de
centaines de milliards d'euros.
Tu parlais d'anticipation de prévisions.
Comment elles sont faites ces prévisions
?
Bah les prévisions donc c'est c'est à
Bercit à la direction générale du trésor
des différentes directions qui
travaillent. ils vont mouliner euh un
certain nombre de de chiffres, les
prévisions de recettes, les prévisions
de dépenses, la croissance, tu vois, euh
et puis bah ils vont sortir des chiffres
macroéconomiques.
Euh bon, moi ce que je crois, moi j'ai
quand même pas une conviction, mais j'ai
je rentre dans cette commission avec une
une idée quand même,
un instinct,
non, pas un instinct, c'est plutôt lié à
une analyse qui est mon analyse de
l'économie. D'accord.
qui est euh euh
en gros pour aller vite, la politique
qui a été menée depuis 2017, c'est une
politique de l'offre et de la
compétitivité. Elle est pas nouvelle en
France, mais elle a été mise à un
niveau, tu vois, euh très haute. Ça
consistait à dire quoi ? c'était de dire
il faut que la France attire les
capitaux parce que tu sais c'est la
fameuse phrase d'Elmou Schmidt
chancelier allemande dans les années 80
qui disait "Les profits d'aujourd'hui
sont les investissements de demain et
les emplois d'après-demain." Bien donc
c'est un peu la même idée. On attire les
capitaux et puis tout ça ça va permettre
de ruseler investissement et emplois
pour attirer les capitaux dans la
concurrence qu'on peut avoir avec
d'autres places internationales.
Il fallait abaisser la fiscalité des
revenus du capital. Donc que fait Macron
quand il arrive au pouvoir ? Il supprime
l'ISF
et il instaure ce qu'on appelle la flat
taxe ou le PFU. Chacun va comprendre.
C'est un bouclier social du capital. Ça
détermine l'idée que le capital ne peut
pas être taxé à plus de 30 %
de d'imposition alors que les revenus du
travail sont peuvent être taxés beaucoup
plus hautes. Donc 30 % c'est la
protection
et en espérant que tout ça va tirer des
capitaux. Alors ça a tiré des capitaux
incontestablement
de quel pays ?
Des investisseurs, des
actionnaires, des beaucoup
d'investisseurs étrangers. beaucoup euh
les nationalités,
non, on les a pas. Il y a il y a des
travaux qui sont demandés là-dessus.
Enfin la France et la France notamment
là dans les dans tous les empreints qui
ont été lancés, on est à on on est on
est dans les rockorman d'Europe en terme
de on a c'est largement plus de 70 % tu
vois d'investissement étranger
aujourd'hui. Mais bon, on attire les
capitaux mais c'était la recherche
d'ailleurs hein. La concurrence c'est
avec d'autres bourses. qu'on attire
bien. Et puis après bah donc cette
politique là, on arrive en 2000 l'année
d'après Covid 2022 2023
et puis
il y a des chiffres de recettes
économiques de fiscalité énorme. Et donc
qu'est-ce que nous disent Bruno Lemire
et tout ça ? disent euh bah vous voyez
bien que on a eu raison de baisser les
impôts puisqu'on a jamais eu autant de
recettes économiques. Bien, nous on a
été quand même quelques-uns à dire "Bon,
attendez, euh c'est une année post
Covid, l'économie est tombée au fond de
la piscine. Quand tu remontes, bah
inévitablement, si tout d'un coup tu as
une croissance très importante parce que
ton économie redémarre par rapport à à
une année où quasiment tout s'est
arrêté, c'est normal que la fiscalité
remonte. toi, c'est normal que tu
produises une activité importante. Et
puis en plus, il y avait un deuxième
phénomène, c'est l'inflation.
Parce que ça a peut-être semblé étonnant
mais quand tu tu as de l'inflation, tu
as plus de TBA. Bon donc la TVA a
explosé et eux nous disaient le maire je
me souviens nous disait bon voyez ça
marche notre politique la prof n'est
jamais eu ton entré
sauf que en 2023 alors en plus avec une
récession de l'activité mondiale
bah toutes les prévisions de de
fiscalité qui étaient basé sur ces deux
années extraordinair tout d'un coup là
ils sont dit tiens il y a moins d'entrée
fiscal tiens bizarrement et puis alors
2024 ça été le record et donc Moi, je
pense que principalement, ça vient de
là, c'està-dire que je pense queils se
sont ils ont vraiment cru ils ont
vraiment cru à la réussite de leur
politique. Ils ont fini par s'intoxiquer
eux-mêmes et quelque part dessiner un
paysage
exceptionnel. Moi, je me souviens encore
Bruno Lemire
mars 2024 en train de dire "La plus
grande réussite de notre politique
économique depuis 2017, c'est la
réindustrialisation.
Cette phrase, elle est extraordinaire.
Alors, ça tombe bien parce que
figure-toi, il y a de jours, j'ai reçu
la cour des comptes qui vient de faire
un rapport avec Moscovici sur 10 ans de
politique industrielle. Même eux
estiment comme ils disent que il y a des
progrès mais que c'est très fragile.
Alors, on est quand même loin la
réindustrialisation.
Et puis moi quand je regarde les
chiffres, par exemple, la part du
travail industriel
des emplois industriels dans l'emploi
global, il a baissé deux points.
D'accord ?
Tu vois, mais n'empêche le maire nous a
présenté ça comme on est les rois du
pétrole, on a été champion de la
réindustrialisation et moi je pense que
à la fin c'est un peu comme toi le c'est
c'est la mariée était trop belle quoi.
Et je pense que ça a fini par influer à
mon avis et c'est ce que je veux
découvrir cette commission d'enquête sur
les fonctionnaires qui eux sont chargés
de mouliner tout ça et de produire des
prévisions.
Il voulait pas il voulait pas contrarier
le chef.
Je sais pas si c'est ça ou si c'est un
contexte ou des fonctionnaires, les
fonctionnaires, ils servent quand même
du politique. Alors ça veut pas dire que
il se plie complètement à ce que dire le
politique mais n'empêche ils vont et
c'est d'ailleurs c'est c'est quelque
part la la beauté d'un état qui a des
fonctionnaires qui quelle que soit la
couleur politique auquelle ils servent
vont vont essayer d' d' d' d' d'adapter
le leur leurs prévisions, leurs
techniques par rapport vont se mettre au
service de cette politique. normal, ils
ont été élus, on se met au service servi
de cette politique. Bon et moi je pense
qu'il y a de ça, c'est-à-dire que on a
une succession d'erreur parce que on a
une politique économique sur l'offre et
la compétitivité qui est en train de
dérailler total. On pourra en parler si
tu veux après. Et
je pense que ils n'ont absolument pas
prévu le fait que ça allait dérailler à
ce point-là. Et donc ça explique que par
exemple en milieu d'année 2024, je suis
reçu par Thomas Casnav à Vercy qui nous
dit qui me dit texta
il était déjà démissionnaire à ce
moment-là puisque le gouverne qui me dit
euh en terme de TVA, en terme d'impôt
sur le revenu, en terme d'impôt sur les
sociétés, les chiffres sont bien bien
plus dramatiques qu'on l'imaginait.
Encore, je dis encore parce que déjà ils
avaient eu une rectification fin
décembre d'une note qui avait été
produite par le trésor qui avait été
cherché le rapporteur euh général de la
commission des finances du Sénat qui
déjà alertait sur le fait que en
quelques semaines les chiffres étaient
pas pas bons. Mais alors là, en juillet,
c'était ce que je t'ai dessiné tout à
l'heure, c'est-à-dire un déficit bien
plus important parce que les recettes
sont pas au rendez-vous. Donc cette
politique, le le résumé de ça, c'est que
c'est pas seulement le problème pour moi
qu'elle n'est pas capable de prévoir euh
elle elle a elle a elle est elle a une
imprévisibilité euh euh grave, mais
c'est surtout qu'en plus elle est en
train de nous emmener dans le mur.
Pourquoi ? Parce que
à force d'avoir baissé les impôts des
plus riches comme jamais on l'a vu, des
ultra riches,
et bien il y a autant d'argent qui
manque à l'État. Et l'an dernier, on le
sait, c'est 62 milliards qui a manqué à
l'État. C'est-à-dire que la perte des
recettes cumulées en 2023 sur l'année
2023 du fait des cadeaux fiscaux des
Macron, c'est 62 milliards.
Donc ce qui me fait dire une chose,
c'est que contrairement à ce que nous
disent les libéraux, la question des
déficites aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'on
dépense trop, c'est qu'il y a moins de
recettes. Et ça, ça a été organisé au
service des plus riches. Et là après tu
regardes, tu dis "Bon bah est-ce que
d'avoir donné autant d'argent aux plus
riches, ça a servi l'économie ou pas ?"
Plus riche à partir de combien ?
Ah le les plus riches, c'est à partir
c'est les c'est les quelques milliers de
personnes qui dans ce pays gagnent
beaucoup d'argent.
Combien ? Bah, par exemple, les 500
patrimoines les plus riches, on a à peu
près 147 milliardaires dans le pays. Les
500 plus riches, donc euh je peux pas te
donner les lesiage exacts, mais euh euh
qui euh j'allais dire ont des revenus
euh euh par an de centaines de millions
d'euros, quoi. D'accord. Je peux pas
dire le chiffre exact, mais les 500 plus
riches, le chiffre que je te donne,
c'est c'est classement de challenge qui
est fait de manière sérieuse chaque
année pour bien comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et à quel point c'est pas
seulement un problème d'inégalité mais
c'est un problème d'argent qui nous
manque. Avec Macron, les 500 personnes
les plus riches de ce pays, elles ont vu
leur patrimoine passer de 2017 à 2024
passer de 21 % du PIB à 42 % du PIB. Je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte, ça
veut dire que tu as 500 personnes qui
aujourd'hui possèdent 42 % de la
richesse nationale, du patrimoine
national, pas du PIB, du patrimoine
national. Enfin, c'est une progression
énorme. Or, dans le même temps, le
patrimoine national, il a pas doublé.
Donc, si leur patrimoine a doublé, bah
inévitablement, ça veut dire qu'il se
ils puissent cet argent sur tout le
monde. C'est mécanique. Enfin, c'est
c'est du marxisme bête, tu vois. Il y a
pas du produit des richesses. Si tu as
des gens qui gagnent tout d'un coup deux
fois plus que deux fois plus qu'il ne
gagnait, que cette richesse globale n'a
pas progressé par deux, bah il a bien
fallu qu'il prenne ailleurs. Et ça ça
n'a pas servi l'économie. Ça a multiplié
par de les dividendes mais ça n'a pas
servi l'économie.
Revenons. Il y a des impôts sur les
dividendes. Non. Oui, mais justement tu
as suivi ce que je t'ai dit tout à
l'heure, comme les impôts sont taxés à
30 % et ben tes dividendes sont moins
taxé tu revenus du travail. Donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Ça c'est une
étude qui est sortie l'an dernier qui a
été faite par l'Institut des politiques
publiques avec Bery. Donc c'est les
chiffres de Bery. C'est imparable. Là
eux ils ont fait une étude là sur ces
147 milliardaires
et ils sont rendus compte de quoi ?
c'est que ces 147 milliardaires, il
payaient moins de 2 % d'impôts sur le
revenu.
Moins de 2 % d'impôts sur le revenu.
Tu payes combien de pourcent toi ?
Bah comme moi je paye
je paye,
je veux pas te dire de bêtises de 1000
par je paye bien je suis à au moins 40
je suis à 30 % d'impôt sur le revenu. 25
% on va dire 25 % d'
Combien tu gagnes ? Moi, je gagne euh
alors attends parce que tu sais, on nous
on nous enlève les impôts maintenant.
Donc euh je touche tous les mois moins
de 5000 €. Euh donc je dois être en tant
que président de la commission des
finances à peu près à 6000 quelque
chose. Euh un peu plus de 6000. Donc on
prend chaque mois de 1300 € d'impôts à
peu près.
Plus les cotisations.
Ah oui oui. Non je te parle que de la
fiscalité là. D'accord. Si si maintenant
je monte la cotisation, je suis
assujetti
je suis assujetti très certainement à
plus de 40 45 % quoi. Bon, donc ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre, je reviens à mon
exemple, c'est que euh
tu redresses ton micro. Voilà, tu
c'est pourtant c'est du gaffeur de bonne
qualité. Je je je meuble pendant que mes
techniciens sont en train de blémir.
Ouais, ça va. Au niveau du son, on est
bon. On est bon.
Donc euh je reviens sur mon calcul que
tu as euh donc les 147 personnes qui
tout qui payent moins de 2 % d'impôt sur
le revenu
et souvent même ça ça s'apparente plus à
zéro. Pourquoi elle paye ça ? Parce que
comme les revenus professionnels ont été
avantagés du fait que on a taxé le
capital en dessous, elles ont transféré
parce qu' ils ont pas mal de d'avocats
fiscalistes qui les conseillent, elles
ont transféré une grande part de leurs
revenus sur leur revenus professionnel.
Et donc quand là tu là ils ont fait le
calcul également, ils ont pris leur
revenu professionnel et ils ont estimé
que ces gens-là ils étaient en gros
imposé à un niveau de 25 % quand les 0,1
% les plus riches de ce pays sont taxés
à 48 %.
Donc tu as 147 personnes ultra riches
qui sont taxé deux fois moins on va dire
que le que les très riches pour aller
vite. Et ben ça chaque année si par
exemple ces gens-là étaient taxés à la
même hauteur que les à ha au 48 % il y
aurait 18 milliards qui rentreraient
dans les caisses de l'État. C'est donc
pas seulement un problème d'égalité,
c'est un problème de dizaines de
milliards qui ont été dilapidés de cette
manière là. C'est ça qui a organisé
Emmanuel Macron.
J'ouvre une petite parenthèse. Est-ce
que le travail il est trop taxé en
France ?
Qu'est-ce que tu entends par le travail
? Excuse-moi parce que
nous on pose des questions. C'estd que
par exemple sur ta fiche de paye
Ouais.
du temps où pr
D'accord. Tu parles de de Est-ce que le
travail salarié est tout taxé ?
C'est est-ce que ça coûte pas trop cher
au patron de payer
?
Par exemple, un patron qui paye son
salarié 2500 balles à la louche, ça lui
coûte 5000 balles.
Ouais. Ouais. Pas tout à fait mais enfin
bon. Ouais.
Ah j'ai dit à la louche.
Ouais ouais.
C'est c'est trop, c'est pas assez.
Non mais c'est faut bien voir ce que
c'est. C'est pas une taxe, c'est de la
cotisation. C'est du ce qu'on appelle du
salaire différé. Euh bon, c'est-à-dire
que pour une on a organisé en France la
protection sociale de manière collective
qui fait qu'une partie de ton salaire en
tant que salarié, une partie du du de
ton salaire du côté patronal est mis en
commun. D'accord ? c'est les cotisations
pour payer ta sécurité sociale et cetera
et cetera, ta tes retraites, enfin tout
ça. Bon, donc pour moi c'est pas des
taxes. Alors donc il y a le débat après
les libéraux disent tout ça coûte trop
cher, le le travail coûte trop cher.
Voilà. Et moi j'ai tendance à penser que
non le travail coûte pas trop cher. Ce
qui coûte trop cher, c'est le capital.
Justement dans ce que l'exemple que je
t'ai donné qui coûte des des dizaines et
dizaines de milliards même plutôt des
centaines de milliards chaque année à
l'État, chaque année à la collectivité,
on s'aperçoit que c'est plutôt les
revenus capital aujourd'hui qui coûtent
trop cher à la collectivité. C'est eux
qui se sont envolés. les revenus du
travail. Moi, je j'estime que euh alors
certes, il y a il y a des boîtes des PME
pour qui j'étais hier à la à la à la une
initiative de la confédération générale
des des PME des PE avec qui je discutais
qui pensent que le travail c'est trop
cher, ils ont du mal. Euh et dans le
même temps, il m'expliquait, moi
j'étais, je trouve que j'ai dirigé une
petite boîte dans dans le domaine de de
la voie. J'ai une petite boîte boîte de
patron. Oui, j'étais chef d'entreprise.
C'est pas mal parce que quand j'ai
affaire à des chefs d'entreprise, je
leur dis bah je trouve que je connais un
tout petit peu le problème. Donc on peut
peut-être parler de des problèmes qu'on
a.
On en profite pour passer un bonjour à
au nom que je cherchais Mathuri Gust.
Ah d'accord. OK. Alors bonjour à
Matrius. Bon euh donc si tu veux alors
là je me je me perd un peu mais
c'est fait exprès.
C'est fait exprès. Mais une petite
boîte.
Je reviens. J'étais pas trop une petite
boîte. J'ordi. Donc je vois bien à peu
près les problèmes des petites boîtes.
C'est qui les les donne d'ordre et les
des petites boîte ? Ils sont
sous-traitantes en général de qui ? Soit
parce que c'est leur client, soit parce
que quelquun c'est souvent les grosses
boîtes. Bon et moi je regarde un peu
quand j'étais pas trop une petite boîte,
je voyais par exemple les contrats que
j'avais qui venaient de très grosse
boîte. En général ça suivait pas
l'inflation. C'est-à-dire que mes
contrats si tu veux le le baissait au
fur et à mesure des années. C'est
souvent ce qui arrive au PME TP.
Autrement dit, j'ai mon technicien qui
va te remettre un peu de scotch sur ton
micro parce que comme on fait des
économies même aussi sur le scotch les
gars.
Ah ouais, je te comprends. C'est ça le
le et puis en plus c'est pas
le coup du scotch. Je j'en profite quand
ils vont te ils vont te mettre ton bout
de scotch. Je vais je vais te prendre
une petite question entre deux. l'impôt
sur les sociétés. Quand par exemple tu
es patron d'une petite PME que tu
t'inquiètes que l'année d'après ça va
être un peu tendu, tu vas mettre un peu
d'argent de côté, tu vas laisser du fric
sur ton compte en banque et à la fin à
la fin de l'année, tu as l'État qui
arrive qui te fait toc toc, mes bons
amis, donnez-moi un peu de sous. Alors
quand tu es dans une petite PME que tu
aimes ton pays, bah tu payes. Mais les
autres boîtes qui font tourner leur
trésorerie dans des pays où ça où ça
permet d'avoir une fiscalité différente
ou qui font tourner avec cinq ou sep
boîtes leur trésorerie sur ces cin ou
sep boîtes pour que bah le contrôleur
des impôts il voit pas la trésorerie ou
il la voit différée ou il se fait pas
taxer. La majeure partie des petites
boîtes elles font pas de l'optimisation
à ce point-là. Et quand tu te retrouves
avec ça, maintenant qu'ils t'ont mis un
bon bout de scotch, tu vas pouvoir
répondre. Je t'écoute.
Mais je vais te répondre mais c'est
c'est la suite de ce que j'étais en
train d'expliquer et je vais te répondre
précisément, c'est que tes petites
boîtes en général, c'est exactement
quelque part comme les salariés. Les
marges,
les les marges des très grosses boîtes,
elles se fait sur les sous-traitants ou
les salariés. C'est pareil quelque part.
C'est-à-dire que ils vont payer parfois
en retard des gens moins pour pouvoir
faire en sorte de d'alimenter leurs
actionnaires par des par l'utilisation
des par une utilisation des bénéfices
qui va puisque c'est le dans notre dans
le société capitaliste tel qu'elle est
aujourd'hui, le seul critère c'est pas
qu'une boîte quelque part perdure qui
qui est qui est un côté patrimonial qui
l'emporte qui fait que tu vas produire,
tu vas t'assurer que l'année prochaine
tu vas continuer. à la nanoseconde la
rentabilité de tes actions avec des
résultats à deux chiffres. Puis si tu as
pas ton résultat à deux chiffres, tes
actionnaires ils vont sur la boîte à
côté. Donc c'est ça le le le juge de
paix du capitalisme aujourd'hui
financiarisé. Bien et donc la pression,
elle se fait sur tous les productifs.
Moi j'ai tendance à dire ça. Elle se
fait sur les salariés, elle se fait sur
les TPE PME et cetera. Et c'est ce que
je disais hier au représentant des TPE
PME. Je disais le problème c'est pas que
le travail vous coûte trop cher, c'est
que la pression qu'on vous fait que vous
avez moins d'argent pour payer ce
travail. Bon et en dernière instance
alors on pourrait se dire
pour investir d'ailleurs
alors oui et pour investir et c donc on
pourrait se dire en dernière instance
bah c'est peut-être parce que a moins de
richesse. Ça pourrait être la solution
sauf que non la richesse elle continue à
croître chaque année. On produit de plus
en plus de richesses. Alors la question
c'est où elle va ? Et bien là tu as eu
la réponse que tu as donné tout à
l'heure. Où elle va principalement
depuis des années ? Elle va dans le
capital. le capital non investi, le
capital financiarisé, des très grosses
boîtes qui en plus de ça peuvent
pratiquer un sport national, c'est que
non seulement leur baisse leurs impôts
pour faire en sorte qu'elle reste, mais
figure-toi qu'elles font aussi de
l'optimisation fiscale pour être sûr
encore d'en payer moins et pour pouvoir
encore une fois alimenter leurs
actionnaires. Et donc les grosses boîtes
dont tu parles qui qui
pratiquent ce qu'on appelle la
délocalisation des profits grâce au prix
de transfert, c'estàd pour aller vite,
tu es une boîte, tu es dans plusieurs
pays et tu vas t'arranger pour déclarer
tes profits dans le pays qui impose le
moins. Par exemple, l'Irlande est un
pays euh absolument connu pour ça. Euh
qui fait que là, en ce moment, au moment
où je te parle, allez, la croissance en
Europe, elle est vers 08. La croissance
en Irlande, elle est plus de deux points
et elle est uniquement construite sur
ces délocalisations de profit.
Donc c'est ça qu'il faut attaquer, une
politique économique et d'ailleurs c'est
ce qu'on a fait. Je sais pas si tu as vu
dans quand je dis 11 et les forces du
NFP, on a on a bougé par amendement le
budget de la nation et on a par exemple
été imposé une taxe qui s'appelle la
taxe Zucman. C'est le nom de
l'économiste qu'il a imaginé, Gabriel
Zucman qui consiste à dire c'est on va
aller taxer ces profits délocalisés.
Comment on fait ? C'est simple. Tu
regardes, tu dis par exle total, bon
exemple total chiffre d'affaires de
Total mondial un/art du chiffre
d'affaires se fait en France. Pendant 2
ans Total a pas payé
un impôt.
On prend une autre boîte que Total Minz.
Min l'exemple. Oui. Enfin bon là, j'ai
pas les chiffres alors à total ça
m'arrangeait. Bon enfin bon n'importe
quelle boîte elle va produire elle va
produire on regarde le chiffre d'affair
qu'elle produit en France. Si elle
produit 25 % de chiffre d'affaires en
France et qu'elle ne paye que 2 % de sa
de son impôt mondial en France, et ben
on va aller rectifier l'impôt qu'elle
doit en France en fonction de son
chiffre d'affaires. On va dire bah là il
y a un problème et donc on va taxer
c'est cette différence
un peu à l'américaine.
C'est pas la même chose. Donc je vais te
répondre après un peu
un peu mais c'est pas la même chose. Les
États-Unis c'est encore autre chose. Et
c'est une taxe. Et figure-toi que cette
taxe si on l'appliquait en France,
elle rapporterait 26 milliards d'euros à
l'État. Alors maintenant, tu entends
bien 26 milliards
plus les 18 ou 19
plus par exemple rétablissement de l'ISF
15 milliards avec un ISF écologique plus
le fait d'aller taxer les super
dividendes 10 milliards. C'est comme ça
qu'on a trouvé nous 58 milliards là en
budget qu'on a mis, on a dit voilà il y
a 58 milliards de recettes, on touche
pas au français, on touche pas au TPE
PME, on touche seulement aux ultra
riches et aux très grosses boîtes. On
amène 58 milliards. Si tu entends bien,
tu te rappelles bien ce que disait ce
que disait Barnier quand il a été nommé
premier ministre, il a dit manque 60
milliards. Et ben nous, on a dit on
amène 58 milliards.
Et alors pour la petite histoire, à la
fin de cette discussion budgétaire qui
était il y a 2 semaines, le gouvernement
quand donc a dit "C'est un scandale,
vous êtes en train de t nous les
Français, tu viens de te montrer que
c'est pas le cas, le gouvernement a fait
le calcul de ce qu'on venait d'amener et
a été obligé d'admettre qu'on était
passé en dessous de 3 % de déficit avec
ces recettes. Autrement dit, le problème
de déficit qui est qui est qui est celui
du pays, on l'avait amené en dessous 3 %
ce qui permettait si on de dégager y
compris des marges pour l'investissement
écologique et cetera. Donc le résumé de
ce que je dis c'est que un déficit en
France le problème c'est des recettes.
De c'est des recettes qui vont aux ultra
riches et aux très grosses boîtes au
capitalisme financiarisé. 3, ça ne
rejaillit pas sur l'économie et 4, ça
fait en sorte que nous payons tous par
les déficits, par la baisse de dépenses
publiques, par les taxations diverses
évaillées. En réalité, nous payons tous
les actionnaires de ces boîtes. C'est ça
que nous payons.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Vas-y.
Quand tu es actionnaire, que tu as une
grosse boîte, que tu as la capacité
d'appeler plein de copains avocats
fiscalistes, que tu as la capacité de
faire bouger tes capitaux avec un
claquement de doigt ou un clavier de
d'ordinateur, que d'ailleurs ton
banquier t'aide à pouvoir optimiser tes
flux. Tu as pas peur, comme après
l'élection de Mitteran que il y ait
certains qui se disent "Bon, maintenant
c'est terminé. Euh euh en France, les
infirmières sont payées à 1500 balles.
Les les pompiers les les les pompiers
sont pas reconnus comme profession à
risque. Euh euh il se passe c, il se
passe ça, euh ça devient compliqué. Et
puis nous, on a la capacité d'acheter un
passeport dans un autre pays où c'est
taxé moins cher. On va se barrer, on va
barrer le siège social de notre boîte
parce que en France, c'est devenu des
communistes.
Hm.
Alors écoute
déjà première réponse, oui, je peux
avoir peur. Mais alors au nom de ça euh
est-ce que on va supporter très
longtemps un système euh qui d'un point
de vue international nous emmène dans le
mur ? va dire au nom du fait de dire ces
gens-là vont partir bah du coup à
l'avance on va baisser leurs impôts.
Alors effectivement ils ont bonne raison
de partir on baisse tellement leurs
impôts.
Et puis ce que et voilà ce que tu as dit
c'est que non seulement on baisse leurs
impôts mais tu as remarqué ça les
empêche pas d'optimiser. Donc en fait
ils font les deux. Donc déjà ma première
réponse elle est là. C'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui, on les taxe moins mais ça
les empêche pas d'optimiser chaque année
à peu près. On estime que l'évasion
fiscale, optimisation, c'est c'est les
calculs de de de sud de sud de finances
qui ont pas été trop remis en question.
En réalité, c'est 80 à 100 milliards que
ça coûte à la collectivité chaque année.
Donc on les impose moins et il continue
à fiscaliser, il continuent à à tricher
avec l'impôt. Donc première réponse,
c'est celle-là que je te fais. Puis la
deuxième, c'est que pour des sais pour
des très riches, c'est pas mal de vivre
en France.
aussi parce que mine de rien en France,
tu bénéficies quand même
d'infrastructure, d'un état
d'état des routes de tu as des services
publics. Bon, même quand tu es très
riche, c'est plutôt plus agréable que
quand tu es dans un pays où finalement
il y a il y a pas tout ça.
Tu as déjà été à Dubaï ?
Non, j'ai j'ai aussi je suis enfin
j'étais en en transit à Dubaï.
Tu t'es jamais baladé dans Dubaï ?
Non.
Tu as jamais posé ton téléphone sur une
table de restaurant à Dubaï ?
Non.
Non, si j'y a pas été, j'ai pas pu trop.
Ouais.
Même à l'aéroport.
Tu as donné l'empreinte de ton IRIS à
l'aéroport ? Non.
Non, je me souviens pas de ça. Non. Non.
Non. Tu as déjà été en Suisse ?
Oui. Oui.
Bon, en terme de sécurité de tout se
passe comment dans ce genre de pays ?
C'est plus safe, ça rassure les riches,
ils se mettent là-bas parce que la
fiscalité est moins forte, c'est 13 %.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. Ils peuvent aller
là-bas. Mais moi, j'observe enfin toi
Oui, oui, oui, mais enfin bon.
d'Ard juste dire au moment où tu as
augmenté au moment où euh on a euh on a
remis en place l'ISF parce que l'ISF on
avait dit euh
si on rétablit l'ISF, les riches vont
partir. Il y a eu très peu de mouvement
en fait, je disais ça comme ça, il y en
a eu très peu. Et quand on a supprimé
l'ISF, il y a pas eu il y a eu un peu de
mouvement mais pas la hauteur de ce que
rapportait l'ISF. Bon, autrement dit,
peut-être déjà qu'il y a des riches qui
acceptent quand même qui accepteront
quand même. J'ai entendu que certains
Ouais, on va dire que j'ai entendu
certains très riches qui disent quand
même c'est pas normal qu'on paye aussi
peu d'impôts. Donc déjà, on peut
peut-être se dire après tout que
certains vont se dire bon bah s'il faut
lâcher 10 % de plus de notre fortune et
que on est tranquille et qu'on peut un
peu plus se regarder dans la glace et
qu'on contribue à la richesse, peut-être
que certains peuvent le faire. Tu vois,
moi je suis pas maniqué. Et puis les
autres, bah il faut peut-être réfléchir
à des contraintes internationales, je
sais pas. Mais en tout cas, on peut pas
continuer comme ça euh à à continuer à
alimenter une caste euh qui gagne
toujours plus d'argent, qui produit des
inalités qui sont insupportables et qui
en plus de ça fait que cet argent-là
nous manque, ne serait-ce que par
exemple c'est Mondada pour investir d'un
point de vue écologique. Enfin, on va
tous dans le mur au niveau de
l'environnement quand même. Tous les
calculs sont actuellement
tous les calculs sont à peu près se
rejoignent sur ce qui manque comme
investissement public pour atteindre les
les objectifs climat. Il y a le dernier
calcul qui avait été fait 2 ans, c'était
Pisaniferie avec quelqu'un qui ils
avaient fait un rapport Pisaniféri
Mafous Pisanifie
pour les gens qui nous écoutent c'était
le conseiller de Macron en 2017 hein
c'est pas un insoumito
il fait un rapport et
comme chaque année l'inaction climatique
coûte toujours plus cher l'année
d'après. Il estime que en 2027 de
mémoire, j'ère pas me tromper un nombre
enfin m'en voudrais pas, il faudrait 37
milliards d'euros d'investissement
public en plus.
Là là, il y a un singang écologiste qui
s'appelle I forc sérieusement qui a fait
le le même calcul 2 ans après.
Maintenant, on en est à 50 milliards.
Pourquoi ? Parce que chaque année où on
tarde, tu as un effet bout de neige qui
fait que si tu veux essayer de r puis un
jour on y arrivera plus, tu vois, ça
sera tellement énorme. Bon, donc cet
argent-là nous manque et que je sache,
il nous manque pour pouvoir continuer
juste à respirer sur cette de
planète quoi. Je veux dire, c'est ça qui
nous manque. Et ben moi je ne supporte
pas un système capitaliste qui estime
que sa seule sa seule valeur c'est
d'enrichir quelques centaines de
personnes dans le monde comme on a
jamais vu dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et alors que il nous manque cet argent
pour investir d'un point de vue
écologique qui en plus de ça si on le
mettait aurait un effet positif sur
toute l'économie parce que si tu
investis 37 milliards dans l'écologie tu
fais travailler des boîtes du BTP pour
l'isolation tu fais si si Je t'assure,
tu fais travailler des tu fais
travailler l'économie.
Après après en terme d'isolation, on
sait pas si c'est si c'est réellement un
gain ou pas un gain telle qu'elle est
faite. Attends bah Prime Redof, c'est
c'est parce que jusqu'à maintenant tu as
des tu as des c'est pas
le diagnostic énergétique
c'est une catastrophe mais c'est pas le
c'est pas pas faut pas tromper entre le
l'outil qu'on met en place et
l'objectif. Je je lis un commentaire
dans les questions. D'ailleurs, les
questions seront sur Twitter aujourd'hui
parce que le PC qui est sur Discord a
rendu son dernier souffle ce soir. Et
donc revenons, revenons. Et comme on
noyote chaque chose sur chaque PC, euh
un commentaire de de Richard,
ça dit taxer, taxer, taxer et taxer.
Voilà, je viens de résumer la LFI.
Voilà. Alors, ça c'est ça c'est
intéressant. Je sais pas qui est Richard
et cetera. Bon mais euh c'est
intéressant
pardon Risichade pardon.
D'accord. C'est intéressant parce que
le le la propagande néolibérale est très
forte parce que elle arrive à faire
croire que quand tu dis que tu vas taxer
des gens qui ont une fortune patrimoine
des revenus qui sont je ne sais pas
combien de fois supérieurs à celui qui
va certainement écrire.
Tu vas finalement atteindre la personne.
Voilà. Tu sais, c'est comme l'histoire
de l'héritage,
la fiscalisation sur les successions.
Ouais, les successions.
En gros, on est passé, on a augmenté
quasiment depuis les années 70
la part de l'héritage dans le patrimoine
des plus riches. Il est passé en gros de
un peu plus de 30 % à 60 %. Autrement
dit, on a une espèce de noblesse
d'argent qui s'est créée qui fait que tu
nais tu es tu es un enfant de riche.
La part de ton patrimoine, il va être de
60 % parce que tu es un enfant parce que
parce qu'il t'a été transmis. C'est pas
que tu as été le chercher.
Moi, je vais dire c'est de l'argent qui
a déjà été fiscalisé. Alors, qu'est-ce
que tu m'ennuies ?
Et ben non, mais juste oui, mais moi je
suis républicain à toi. Liberté,
égalité, fraternité. Et donc moi, je
suis pas pour des noblesses, je suis pas
pour la noblesse de sang, je suis pas
pour la noblesse d'argent. Je pense que
quand même à un moment donné, voilà
c'est un c'est un débat, je pense qu'il
faut redistribuer et donc c'est pas
normal que tu es une espèce de caste qui
s'entretienne comme ça du simple fait
d'être bien né dans la bonne maison par
rapport à quelqu'un qui sera né dans la
mauvaise maison à côté. Donc il faut
arriver à à rectifier. Et quand tu dis
ça, quand tu dis ça là, tu vois,
redresse-moi ton petit micro là.
Même pas ce micro. tu me mettras une
veste noire moins surannée la prochaine
fois parce que comme ça mon chatterton
va pouvoir coller.
Donc si tu veux
quand tu
ces gens que tu vas vouloir taxer, c'est
déjà pas 85 % des Français qui n'ont pas
d'héritage.
C'est pas les 10 % de gens qui ont un
héritage mais qui ont un héritage tel
qu'en général il passent en dessous du
seuil qui permet qu'en dessous de 150000
€ tu es pas taxé. Donc en fait tu vas
commencer à concerner 5 % des plus
riches. Et là les gens dont je te parle
là c'est allez moins d'un % des gens. Et
pourtant, on va arriver à faire croire,
la propagande va arriver à faire croire
que la personne qui a une petite baraque
qui va sûrement même pas être taxée,
c'est sa résidence principale.
C'est quoi une petite baraque résistance
principale ?
Je sais pas, je sais pas. De pièces
quelque part, tu vois. Euh et ben lui si
jamais on parle de taxer ces héritages
là, mon dieu, ils vont me taxer mon
héritage. Il en aura peut-être même pas,
il en aura peut-être même pas à
transmettre ou ou en dessous d'un d'un
chiffre tel, il aura même pas de taxe à
payer. Ça ça c'est fort. Ça c'est fort.
C'est-à-dire le libéralisme arrive à
penser que tu as une solidarité. Tout le
monde est solidaire quelque part de la
taxation sur les plus riches. Bon bah il
faut arriver à sortir de ça quoi.
Pendant que mon technicien va aller te
remettre un coup de gaffeur. Il marche
pas le gaffeur.
c'est c'est du c'est du gaffeur
avec un aimant. D'ailleurs, je te repose
une petite question. Il l'aiment il est
dans ma poche.
Ah tu m'as piqué l'enté
mon aimant.
Remets-moi l'ins derrière pendant que il
va se faire tirer les oreilles derrière.
Moi je vais je vais meubler pendant ce
temps-là.
Je te dis voilà est-ce que tu as déjà
des été discuté avec les les plus riches
? Est-ce que arrête de toucher ton micro
est-ce que à mon avis tu lui brûles les
oreilles ? Est-ce que tu as déjà été
discuté à bâton repu autour d'une bière
d'un ruinard ou d'un cristal rodrir
autour de tout ça ? Et tu as été discuté
avec lui et il t'a dit bon alors
c'est le nivellement vers le bas. Tu
comprends que machin on va donner notre
pognon à des gens qui bossent pas, qui
vont pas se lever pour travailler. Ils
sont ultra aidés à rien faire.
Ça continue, ça continue. Tu vas me
coller mon aimant et mon gaffeur
correctement parce que la dernière fois
que je meuble encore comme ça, je vais
encore me faire tirer les oreilles que
je parle trop. Donc désolé pour ça mais
je couvre mon technicien tu vois. Et
donc est-ce que tu as pas l'impression
que il manque de de communication ? Il y
a un manque de communication entre toi
la gauche et les les ultra riches et les
les très très très riches. Tu as pas
l'impression que Ah ouais là là il t'a
il t'a saucissonné ça ? Attention le ça
c'est du micro saucissonné. Et donc
c'est bon, on peut y aller là. Merci.
retourne derrière ta caméra avant que je
me fâche.
Et donc, tu as pas l'impression que ça
pourrait peut-être s'arranger en
discutant avec les ultra riches en
disant bah là c'est pas du nivellement
vers le bas, on a besoin d'avoir une
population en bonne santé parce qu'une
population en bonne santé, elle peut
mieux innover, elle s'inquiète moins
pour l'avenir. Et ensuite, on va revenir
sur la commission des finances et les
prévisions, les anticipations et les
prospectives. Bah,
c'est surtout que une population en
bonne santé qui gagne un peu plus sa
vie, elle va acheter des produits.
D'accord ? appelle la consommation
populaire. En général, en France, c'est
ça qui tout la croissance. Et la fin du
fin, ta croissance, elle a plutôt
l'ultra riche dont tu vas parler
à un moment donné, ça lui soucie quand
même. Donc déjà, il a il a lui l'intérêt
à ça en réalité. Bon, le problème, c'est
que euh je vais venir non, j'ai pas été
discuté avec les ultra riches dont tu
parles.
Même pas un petit ruinard,
un blanc de blanc. L'abalcool est
dangereux pour la santé. Ouais. Euh
écoute, non, je sais pas, enfin bon,
j'arrive, je parle avec des
représentants de patron, mais je suis
pas sûr que il fasse partie à ce pointlà
des ultra riches. Je veux dire, je je
parle avec tout le monde, y compris des
gens qui défendent ce qu'ils disent à
peu près ce que tu dis. Je sais pas si
Tu as jamais fait une soirée ?
Une soirée ?
Ah non non non, désolé. Non non euh non,
moi j'essaie déjà j'ai déjà du justement
j'ai déjà du mal à euh assez assez de
comment dire assez de choses à faire à
convaincre tous ceux qui ont intérêt à
la politique que je défends que
justement contrairement à ce que
peut-être dit la personne qui a réagit
notre idée est pas de taxer taxer tout
le monde mais peut-être juste d'aller
répartir les richesses autrement pour
que tout le monde vive un peu mieux
quoi. Euh voilà donc déjà j'ai déjà ça
c'est un travail nécessaire. Alors, tu
es écolo, tu parles de croissance,
croissance, croissance.
Ouais, tu as raison.
Alors,
bien vu, bien vu. C'est un problème,
c'est Bien vu,
bien vu.
C'est tout ce que tu me dis ? Bien.
Non, non, bien non, non, tu as raison.
C'est nous à un moment donné, on avait
banni le mot croissance de nos nos
programmes. On parlait de de relance de
l'activité et à chaque fois en en
prenant soin de dire qu'il faut que ça
soit écologiquement soutenable puisqu'on
défend la règle verte au niveau
économique. Alors l'idée c'est de la
règle verte c'est de d'avoir un grand
principe directeur pour une
planification écologique et de ne pas
produire et consommer puisque la terre
ne peut absorber. Tu sais c'est ce jour
qui chaque année avance enfin avance
dans le mauvais sens. Je crois que
maintenant on est fin juillet. hein.
Donc en quelques décennies, on est passé
de fin décembre à fin juillet, au moment
où la terre, ça y est, on a on a
consommé tout ce qu'elle pouvait
produire. Donc, tu as raison, il faut
faire gaffe avec le mot croissance. Mais
ne pas oublier une chose aussi, c'est
que quand on parle de croissance, euh
c'est pas seulement quelque chose qui
alimente une activité qui se forcément
peu le je veux dire que une infirmière,
elle elle produit, elle fait de la
croissance. Euh des enseignants font de
la croissance. euh des salariés qui vont
travailler euh des gens qui vont
travailler dans les dans des dans
l'énergie renouvelable font de la
croissance. Bon, donc c'est pas tu la
croissance est pas forcément mauvais en
soi. Euh mais comme le mot est biaisé,
c'est vrai qu'il faut peut-être faire
gaffe pas l'utiliser. Mais en tout cas,
c'est bien que tu sois colo. Alors, on
va revenir sur la commission des
finances mais on repartira après
derrière sur les énergies entre
guillemets renouvelables, les batteries,
le nucléaire, la fonction exponentielle,
le rapport midose et on en pass des
meilleurs. Revenons à la prévision,
l'anticipation et les prospectives de
finances. Est-ce que les scénarios,
les prospective de nos fonctionnaires de
Bercy
on leur fait des petits stress tests de
temps en temps ? C'est imagine-toi,
nous on ou ou quelqu'un d'autre, on
vient et on dit "Bon bah écoute, ton
scénario c'est un peu le rond rond
quotidien. Euh c'est quand tout se passe
bien, quand la mer est calme, quand euh
il y a des petites vaguelettes et que le
rayon de soleil te frappe le visage.
Mais imagine-toi, dans 10 minutes, je te
mets la tempête de Méditerranée que tu
as pas vu venir avec le penant qui te
met bien ta race. Qu'est-ce que tu fais
? Tu copes avec un petit godet ? Tu as
prévu ton gilet de sauvetage ? Tu as tes
tes canaux de sauvetage qui sont
opérationnels. Comment ça s'appelle
d'ailleurs le truc que tu balances à la
flotte et qui explose ? Euh moi,
j'appelle ça un bib mais c'est Ouais. Tu
as tu as tu as ton annexe qui peut
supporter ta radio fonctionne bien.
Est-ce que tu comprends le parallèle ?
Est-ce que il y a des stress tests sur
les scénarios ? Je te pourquoi là il y a
la guerre. Est-ce qu'ils ont vu vu la
guerre ? On te répond direct. Est-ce que
leur prévision économique, s'il y a une
guerre, s'il y a une tempête, s'il y a
quoi que ce soit, ça tient la route ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un scénario A, B, C ?
Est-ce que il y a des gars qui se sont
formés ? Et figure-toi que c'est une
très bonne question et je compte leur
poser des questions comme ça de ce type.
Ce que tu viens de dire,
je te fasse des fiches.
Ah mais ouais, vas-y, vas-y, viens. Mais
je t'ai écouté là. Non, non, c'est je
compte leur poser des questions comme
ça. C'est un peu la même question que
celle que celle en entrée où je disais
euh j'aimerais savoir quelle a été
l'influence
euh des données produites par des
ministres politiquement dans les calculs
de ces techniciens. Voilà. Alors, c'est
en l'occurrence, c'est un peu l'inverse
de ce que tu dis. C'est des données qui
enjolivent le monde. La croissance est
là.
Des lunettes roses.
Voilà. Du lunettes rose. Bon, mais de la
même manière euh
la question est la question est
intéressante aussi. Est-ce que est-ce
que par exemple on anticipe très vite
quand on sent que ça se retourne ? Tu
vois ? Euh un exemple, un exemple. Oui.
Et un exemple. Puis la mitéradis, ça me
parle beaucoup parce que les phénomènes
de réchauffement de l'eau en ce moment
produisent chaque été maintenant des
phénomènes catastrophique en Méitadé qui
s'apparentent à des cyclones et qui
deviennent vraiment problématiques. Bon,
pour en parler si tu veux. Euh le le
Attends, je reviens à ce que j'étais en
train de te dire. le euh je donne un
exemple le
en 2023 euh les ministères desconies et
finances ont voulu mettre une taxe sur
les énergéticiens.
Ils ont dit elle va rapporter 3
milliards.
Donc inévitablement, je suppose qu'à Ber
on a mouliné là-dessus.
Au final, elle a rapporté 250 millions
d'euros.
Pourquoi ? Comment ? Qui s'est trompé ?
Toi, c'est intéressant. Bon, mais je
suppose que là, c'est typiquement à mon
avis à un moment donné des prévisions
qui se font en fonction de données qui
sont qui les donne. Moi ça, je veux
essayer de savoir.
Les astrologues,
bah non, les astrologues je crois pas.
Mais est-ce que c'est les politiques qui
ont donné ça au doigt mouillés ?
Est-ce que c'est un cabinet de conseil ?
Est-ce que c'est les services de Bercy
qui se plantent ? Est-ce que tu vas
auditer les sondes ?
Les sondes du ministère, celles qui
prennent la température, le sens du vent
et alors c'est qui c'est qui qui est-ce
que c'est
on sait rien, je vais le savoir.
Ah oui.
Hm. Je sais pas qui est qui sont les
sondes des ministères. Alors, il y a une
sonde quand même qui elle est
faut on a quand même encore des on a des
services qui fonctionnent bien quand
même. L'INC fonctionne pas mal quand
même pour rendre hommage les choses
publiées par l'INC, ça tient globalement
la route. C'est des sondes quelque part.
Ça produit des données. D'ailleurs,
c'est un peu une forteresse dans la
forteresse de Bery comme assez jalouse
de ce prérogative, mais ils produisent
des choses utiles, intéressantes.
Tout est pas quand même acheté, tu on a
quand même un état qui continue à
fonctionner. Justement, c'est
intéressant de savoir pourquoi il a à ce
pointl déraillé. Euh moi j'ai tend
tendance à penser que le rôle des
politiques a été prédominant euh dans le
monde qu'ils ont voulu voir se voir se
dessiner par rapport à leur politique et
que euh que c'est ça qui va être mis en
question.
Tu vas pouvoir aussi auditionner la
Banque de France ou
Oui, on va bien sûr la Banque de France.
Euh
le président de la Banque de France.
Oui, bien sûr. Le gouverneur de la
banque de France.
Pardon ? Merci.
Bien sûr.
Et et tu l'attends chaudement. Euh tu
attends ses réponses ? Tuattends ouis.
Alors pour être exact en fait que ça
soit la Banque de France, le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques,
Moscovici,
il y a il y a eu pas mal d'organismes
qui ont été quand même très prudents au
moment où les chiffres les premiers
chiffres avaient été donnés fin 2023.
Moskovicier pour parler de problème de
crédibilité. Pourquoi ?
Donc si tu veux euh et je crois que la
Banque de France était quand même assez
assez prudente, pas assez mais assez
prudente. Donc ça je crois pas que le
écoute les les prévisions de croissance
de la Banque de France très intéressant
je pense.
Oui justement mais c'est pas mais elles
étendent ça de des prévisions elles
étendent ça des prévisions
de Bery.
le tu es marin. Donc si je te mets sur
un bateau et tu sais que si tu vires de
bord et que le vent et souffle très fort
et que si tu as pas prévenu tes copains
qui sont devant toi, ils vont tous se
prendre un gros coup de baum dans la
tête.
C'est un peu la même chose en économie.
Quand tu sens pas les coups les le les
changements de tendance arriver, tu te
prends des grands coups de baum dans la
tête. Tu es pas économiste, même si tu
as l'air de toucher quand même un peu ta
bille. Comment tu vas faire pour pas te
faire endormir en face de toi ? Tu
comprends ma question ? préfère endormir
qu'on te raconte des billes ve et que on
te mène
genre c'est pas notre faute, vous
comprenez, c'était difficile
euh j'avais mal au ventre, je suis pas
venu ce matin travailler, c'est la il y
a il y a il y a pas responsable, on
n'est pas responsable.
Non, j'ai pas une formation
d'économiste, mais ça me rappelle une
histoire.
Tu es bien entouré ? Ouais, il y a pas
que ça. C'est c'est que en fait euh en
en quand j'ai été élu pour la première
fois président de la commission des
finances, c'était en 2022
et à l'époque, je sais pas si tu te
souviens, mais il y a eu quand même des
gros titres sur le comment ça un
insoumis, président de la commission des
finances et puis
et alors
et puis oui, mais je te dis et qu'est-ce
qu'il est ? Il a tr il a il a qu'une
licence, il vient. Bon c moi j'avais
répondu à l'époque que j'avais 40 ans de
militantisme teinté de marxisme et que
ça aidait quand même un peu finalement
de de En plus j'ai fait de bosser toute
sa vie ça aide aussi c'est con mais tu
vois bon donc j'avais pas
tu fais tes déclarations d'ursaf à la
main ? Oui. Euh enfin bon, oui, enfin,
en tout cas, elles sont faites euh de
facto de fête, mais bon, enfin bon,
bref, euh ce que j'ai voulu ce que je
veux dire par là, c'est que euh tu dis
"Je touche ma bille, en tout cas, je
comprends un peu l'économie." Bon, parce
que c'est pas une mauvaise formation le
militante. Voilà, euh de ce point de
vue-là, on est un peu attentif aux
choses qui se passent. Mais
il y a une différence entre organiser
une kermesse avec un vin chaud et et
tenir les finances de l'État quand même,
je l'avocat du diable.
Ouais. Ouais. La preuve que bah écoute,
vu les résultats, excuse-moi, mais vu
les résultats qu'on vient de constater
de la part de gens qui donnaient des
leçons à tout le monde et qui continu à
en donner si tu veux, je me sens pas
très très euh j'ai j'ai pas trop honte
quoi, tu vois. Je pense que la
comparaison, elle peut se donner. Voilà,
donc j'ai pas trop de problème
là-dessus. Mais tu dis euh oui, on alors
pour être exact, tu dis euh on est
entouré,
un député, il a des collabes. Donc on va
aussi faire en sorte que euh de de se
faire entourer par des collabes qui eux
ont euh pour les uns ont fait des études
quand même assez poussées en matière
légiste et économique, fiscale. On a
aussi des administrateurs, des
fonctionnaires. Nous aussi, moi le
président de la commission des finances,
j'ai il y a plusieurs administrateurs
qui travaillent au service de la
commission et qui m'aident. Donc on est
euh là, ils vont aussi m'aider en
fonction de moi de de pistes politiques
sur lesquelles je vais les mettre mais
ils m'aident donc je suis pas c'est pas
berim mais enfin on a quand même un on a
quand même des gens qui sont là pour
nous épauler et vérifier que ce qu'on
dit à un moment donné ça tient un peu la
route d'un point de vue théorique on va
dire.
Bon euh je mets encore une parenthèse
dans la parenthèse dans la parenthèse.
Imagine-toi bon à Ber il y a des
fonctionnaires qui bossent. On a déjà
été invité à Ber, on a même visité le
bureau d'Emmanuel Macron quand il était
ministre. Mais c'est pas Emmanuel Macron
qui nous a fait visiter son bureau. Et
puis on a d'ailleurs visité le Lilior
qui a été construit au-dessus de Bercy
qui a servi peut-être deux fois depuis
le tournage de mission impossible et qui
peut plus servir parce que c'est il y a
trop de vent ou que peut-être bon. Et
ces gens-là, quand ils ont bien vu que
le ministre euh bah peut-être s'il est
il a été averti,
ils ont peut-être vu que le ministre il
restait sur sa ligne. Bon, il ils ont
peut-être rappelé à monsieur le ministre
que bon bah ça partait un peu en
sucette. Il fallait faire quoi ? Il
fallait démissionner.
Alors pour euh
il fallait se sacrifier pour la France
pour essayer d'être pour essayer d'être
le plus honnête possible.
Est-ce que tu as vu le monument au mort
qui a dans Bercy ?
Euh qui est en bas ? Non. Ouais. Ouais,
je l'ai vu. Bien sûr. Oui, mais j'ai
déjà été dans le bureau où tu as été
plusieurs fois.
Oui, c'est austère hein.
Ah ouais, tu trouves
? Vous avez trouvé ça très sombre.
Ah ouais, ouais, ouais. Enfin bon. Euh,
écoute, pour être honnête, si on prend
le maire, euh, je suis pas sûr que soit
le plus responsable de la bande pour
pour être clair avec toi. Voilà. Moi,
j'ai pas des mauvais rapports avec lui.
On a des rapports assez on a toujours eu
des rapports assez francs. Et au moins
lui, ce que j'ai trouvé pas mal dans la
période qui est passée, c'est que
contrairement à certains vis-à-vis de
gens comme moi, soumis et autres, il a
pas trop utilisé des espèces de
polémiques d'accusations, tu vois,
commentantisme
ou je sais pas quoi. Enfin, tu vois, on
nous dépint. Bon, il a plutôt sur le
fond. Alors, on n'est pas du tout
d'accord. Ilassume sa politique. Mais au
moins, je trouve que c'est plus
intéressant quand tu as un mec en face
de toi qui est pas en train de te dire
de qui est pas en train de casser la
protection sociale en disant qu'il fait
l'inverse ou de casser les retraites en
disant qu'il fait l'inverse.
Pense à qui ?
Ah bah je pense au Premier ministres qui
se sont succédés. Borne P euh je
rappelle Pénico qui a attaqué la la le
code du travail en disant qu'elle
qu'elle renforçait la protection
sociale. C'est c'est le principe
rouélien. Tu sais
euh tu fais la tu prépares la paix la
guerre c'est la paix et cetera de cet
inverse les mots. Enfin bon bref euh lui
au moins il assume. Lui il défend la
politique de la compétitivité.
Je favorise les revenus capitaux, je
vais pas te la refaire. Bon, il a su
bien euh et euh et je sais que début
2024, quand les chiffres ont pas été au
rendez-vous, lui il était pour un projet
de loi de finance rectificative, ce que
moi je réclamais aussi parce que ça
permettait à l'Assemblée de se saisir de
la question et de ne pas subir des
baisses de dépenses publiques décidées
par décret, c'est ce qui s'est passé.
Voilà, je préférais qu'il y a un débat à
l'assemblée qu'on puisse dire bah tiens,
pourquoi on va pas chercher des recettes
? lui était pour et manifestement il a
pas eu gain de cause. S'il a pas eu gain
de cause, c'est pour ça que ça
m'intéresse et que tu as compris, je
vais auditionner les premier ministres à
tal borne et cetera mais je veux aussi,
c'est pour ça que je voudrais bien
auditionner aussi des gens de l'Élysée
parce que je voudrais savoir qui en
définitive à un moment donné a fait en
sorte que il y ait pas de projet de loi
de finance rectificatif. Ça m'intéresse
alors
pour pour les traces de tout ce travail
payé avec nos impôts et la sueur de
notre front parce que Infiné c'est c'est
nous
c'est nous globalement collectivement
et euh
s'il y a des pièces qui disparaissent
est-ce qu'il y a des archivistes ?
Est-ce que c'est archivé ? Est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a des SMS ? Est-ce que
les SMS sont archivés ? Est-ce que ça
fait partie de Comment ça se passe ? Tu
vas auditionner aussi les archivistes ?
Alors, je peux aller chercher tous les
documents déjà que je veux à Ber si tu
as suivi cet été avec Charles
avec Charles de Courson, on a été
chercher des documents qu'on devait nous
donner, qu'on nous a refusé.
Grande première.
Alors, mais tu sais pourquoi on te les a
refusé ? Oh
oui, oui, je sais pourquoi mais c'est
quand même incroyable par cont. Je sais
pourquoi on te les a refusé, mais est-ce
que tu sais pourquoi on a pu te fermer
la porte au nez ?
Tu sais pourquoi toi ?
Ah bah, je te pose la question.
Ah non non.
Ah non. Est-ce que parce qu'il y a pas
de sanction parce qu'il y a pas Non mais
parce qu'il y a pas de sanction.
Oui oui, tu as raison. Enfin, la
sanction si la sanction ça peut être je
suis même pas sûr qu'on ait besoin de
l'utiliser parce que moi je pense qu'on
va on va censurer le gouvernement au
Barnier son budget. Donc
on par de ça après hein.
Ouais. Mais la sanction ça peut être
quand même un recours au Conseil
constitutionnel
pour si si pour l'ensemble de ce qui
s'est passé. Ça peut être une sanction
de dire
c'est une tape sur les doigts, c'est
boum boum pan cucu tu as pas été gentil
ou c'est 30 tôles avec 30 t à moins de
ruquer le budget, c'est rarement ça
malheureusement mais ça peut être ça au
nom des entorses à la constitution, il y
en a eu plusieurs mais celles-là en font
partie. Normalement, tu ne peux pas dire
au rapporteur général de budget et au
président de la commission des finances,
non, on vous donne pas les documents
auxquels la Constitution vous donne le
droit. Au moins les consulter, au moins
les consulter. C'est incroyable ce qui
s'est passé est incroyable. Je pense que
je suis le premier président de la de la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale de toute la 5e République à
qui à un moment donné Matillon et Ber
ont dit non, on vous donnera pas des
documents financiers. Ça c'est
proprement incroyable.
Pourtant Charles, il est pas marxiste
léniniste,
gauche, gauche, gauche.
Non, pas du tout. Mais quelle quelle a
été sa réaction ? Tu as discuté avec On
était Oui. Oui. Bah tous les deux parce
que Charles de Courson, on est il est
comme moi, il est très républicain et
comme moi, il est très jaloux des
prérogatives de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Parlement par rapport à l'exécutif.
Donc pour te répondre, non euh c'était
quelque chose qu'il mettait dans une
colère, c'est il est il est pas explosif
mais elle était assez elle était elle
était elle était pas finte. On était
réellement en colère.
Je te je te pose. Bon, on passe on passe
sur le budget un petit peu sur le
budget.
Tu sais ce que c'est un fond vautour ?
Oui, bien sûr.
C'est quoi un fond vautour ? Un fond
vautour, c'est euh si tu veux par
exemple un fond de pension qui à un
moment donné va fondre euh sur euh une
boîte ou sur euh euh une activité
quelconque et va euh
fondre fondre fondre.
Oui. fondre comme un vautour. Voilà. Et
qui va euh
tout d'un coup préhempter justement
acheter
euh justement le le les actions de cette
boîte qui va avoir une action. Alors
pourquoi on dit vos tours ? c'est qu'en
général son action n'a même pas une
vocation à avoir un une vision ce que
j'appelle entrepreneurial ou
patrimoniale de la boîte sur lequelle il
va fondre, mais uniquement la manière
dont il va faire des bénéfices à court
terme.
La curée.
Voilà, c'est ça ce qui est ce qui est un
bon résumé de ce que j'appelle le
capitalisme financiarisé.
Tu as étudié un peu l'Argentine ? Euh
oui, alors au moment Oui. au moment de
euh j'ai étudié au moment où le FMI s'en
est mêlé et cetera et où euh d'ailleurs
l'Argentine avait refuser à un moment
donné de se plier au FMI. D'ailleurs,
tu as déjà été en Argentine ?
Euh non, je suis jamais allé. Non.
Je te conseille de le premier du mois en
Argentine, le jour de paye devant les
banques. Très intéressant.
Revenons, revenons
à nos fonds vutour, à la dette de la
France, au budget.
Pourquoi on nous dit "Oh là là, si le
budget n'est pas voté, ça va être la
apocalypse". On pourra peut-être même
pas payer les fonctionnaires
tout simplement parce que Barnier essaye
espère sauver sa peau. Euh Macron aussi
euh par ce genre de de de côté très
alarmiste
ou peut-être que tu es pas assez
informé, que tu connais pas assez à la
finance internationale et que tu vois
pas les grands cercles de vautour
au-dessous de nos têtes ? Moi je crois
pas ça. Je crois pas à ça.
Je crois pas à ça. Alors déjà je déjà
premier point premier point excuse-moi.
Premier point il n'y a pas en France de
risque de shotdown.
Alors on parle en français ici
il y a pas en France de risque on éteint
la lumière, on peut plus lever l'impôt,
on peut plus payer les fonctionnaires,
on peut plus assurer que l'État
fonctionne. Ça te va mieux ? Voilà.
Merci.
Donc
oblige pas à me répéter hein.
Non t'inquiète. En plus je dis rarement
l'anglais. Je parle je parle l'anglais
comme une vache. Euh donc pourquoi on
peut pas ? Parce que il y a des
dispositifs dans les bu dans le le le la
5e République qui permettent notamment
un truc qui s'appelle la loi spéciale
qui fait qu'en fin du fin, tu votes des
ordonnances qui vont permettre que tant
que tu as pas finalisé un budget, bah tu
vas appliquer le budget de l'an dernier
qui va te permettre de lever les impôts.
Donc il y a pas de risque, d'accord ? Il
y a pas de risque de ça. Alors après,
est-ce que il y a un risque tel que
ça peut inquiéter
les marchés financiers, tout ça qui
pourrai se mettre à, je veux dire, se
comporter avec la France comme ils sont
comportés avec la Grèce ? Je ne crois
pas. Je vais dire pourquoi je crois pas.
Parce que bon malant quand même la
France elle reste une valeur sûre. Le
patrimoine, les actifs de la France sont
infiniment plus importants que son
déficit.
On oublie de le dire mais c'est un peu
comme si on oublie c'est un peu comme si
demain je te prête de l'argent pour
t'acheter quelque chose pour refaire la
toiture.
Voilà pour refaire ta toiture, on va
dire "Ah dis donc qu'est-ce que je t'ai
endetté à temps et puis mais d'un autre
côté en fait en réalité tu as 10 autres
baraques quelque part qui font que
jamais à aucun moment tu peux être en
séation de paiement. Ton patrimoine est
tellement important que tu peux pas être
en séation de paiement. La France, c'est
ça. Le patrimoine de la France et même
simplement de l'État est infiniment bien
plus important que son déficit.
Attends, c'est pour bien te suivre.
Quand tu dis le patrimoine,
patrimoine c'est toute la richesse,
ce qu'on peut
toute la richesse nationale,
ce qu'on peut hypothéquer.
Oui, mais c'est ce que tu produis comme
richesse chaque année qui va te
permettre de savoir que l'État peut pas
être en faillite, la France peut pas
être en faillite. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ?
D'accord. Et là, tu es en train de me
dire que les assurances vies peuvent pas
être en faillite non plus parce que
c'est les obligations qui sont garanties
par l'État. C'est ça.
Ah si justement pourquoi à ton avis
elles seront garanties par l'État ?
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi à chaque fois
Pourquoi à chaque fois c'est une bonne
piste pourquoi à chaque fois que tu as
une bonne perche
un partenaire public privé
les boîtes qui vont investir demandent
une une garantie c'est l'état toujours.
Demande pas la garantie du marché
internationaux au monde elle demande la
garantie de l'État. C'est parce qu'elles
savent qu'en dernière instance un État
comme la France, il va pas être en
faillite, faut arrêter. Il va toujours
payer.
Il va toujours avec de la monnaie de
singe.
Non, justement non parce qu'on parce que
faut être faut être sérieux. On produit
je veux dire bonhomme mal, on produit
suffisamment de richesse pour que à
aucun moment cette en cessation de
paiement. Et il y a un deuxième facteur
qu'on oublie trop souvent, c'est que
pour tes marchés, les obligations
délivrées par un état comme la France,
elles sont extrêmement intéressantes.
Autrement dit, ça va peut-être paraître
bizarre, mais les marchés seraient
malheureux si la France empruntait
moins. Par exemple, les marchés
aujourd'hui,
ça les satisfont pas du ça les satisfait
pas tellement la politique allemande
parce que c'est des c'est des pouvoir à
un moment donné prêté à des États. C'est
une assurance, j'allais dire de de au
moins que tu as une partie de ce que tu
vas mettre comme argent sur les marchés
qui t'est garanti. C'est quelque chose
qui va permettre après éventuellement
d'avoir d'autres opérations plus
dangereuses, plus Tu vois,
tu m tu tu me sens venir là. Vas-y.
On fait plus de blé en protant aux
pauvres parce qu'on leur prête plus
cher. Là le taux de la France il est
passé auudess de la la Grèce.
Ouais d'accord. OK. Bon enfin il est pas
il est il est le taux de la France là
tel qu'on se parle en ce moment il est
moins important qu'il y a un an. Donc
soyons soyons Non mais faut faut pas
enfin ça les gens qui jouent ce jeu ce
jeu-là les gens qui jouent ce jeu-là en
réalité ils cherchent à alerter toujours
plus pour qu'on est tendance t à dire ah
vite prenons le le budget barnier puis
vite faisons les baisses de dépenses
publiques pour rassurer les marchés. Moi
je te dis une chose aujourd'hui c'est
pas que je cultive les déficites pour
les déficites. Les déficits me posent un
problème tel qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
pour France parce que ils ont été créés
pour abaisser les impôts des plus
riches. Autrement dit, je suis pas
d'accord que la France s'en dette pour
faire des cadeaux fiscaux à monsieur
Arnaud. Voilà, je suis d'accord que la
France s'endette pour investir en
matière écologique et cetera. Donc c'est
ça qui me pose un problème. Mais le
problème qui est le problème qui est qui
est posé aujourd'hui, je vais très clair
avec toi, le déficit de la France
aujourd'hui, la dette de la France
aujourd'hui, la charge de la dette de la
France aujourd'hui qui est de 1,9 % de
PIB qui est prévu à 27 en 2027, elle est
supportable.
Prévue par qui ? Par les mêmes
astrologues que la dernière fois.
Ouais, globalement. Oui, mais là en
l'occurrence c'est plutôt une prévision
pessimiste. D'accord. Donc elle est elle
est supportable.
Je ne l'accepte pas parce que je
n'accepte pas qu'elle a été créée, tu
l'as compris, pour faire des cadeau plus
riche. Mais elle est supportable et il
faut arrêter de dire il faut arrêter de
dire attention demain la France ça peut
être la Grèce, on peut être en faille
XR. Je n'y crois absolument pas. Je
pense que tout ça c'est fait pour
effrayer et faire en sorte de faire une
politique qui baisse les dépenses
publiques de façon à ce que euh à partir
de là le privé commence à s'emparer de
ce que jusqu'à maintenant le public euh
pouvait euh pouvait euh proposer. Voilà,
je pense que c'est là. Et je vais te
dire une deuxième chose,
il faut pas regarder seulement la dette
publique pour juger de la santé d'un
état, faut regarder aussi la dette
privée. Pourquoi je te dis ça ? Parce
que la crise des suprmes, c'est la dette
privée, c'est pas la dette publique. Et
alors ça va peut-être ê étonner, mais il
y a un pays qui a une dette globale bien
plus importante que la France, c'est les
Pays-Bas. La dette des Pays-Bas est 240
% du PIB.
Par qui ?
Bah, c'est une grosse partie de dette
privée, plus grosse partie.
Mais cette dette, elle est tenue à
l'étranger ou elle est tenue la dette
bas moins qu'à l'étranger que la France,
mais elle est quand même pas mal. Mais
ce qui est intéressant de savoir, c'est
que l'endettement est important
et donc c'est ça qui qui à un moment
donné, il faut comprenant une chose,
c'est que si ton endettement est pas
public, quelque part quand la France
s'endettete publiquement, elle va s elle
va permettre aux citoyens français
d'être moins endetté qu'un citoyen des
Pays-Bas. Et quelque part pour
l'économie euh c'est pas forcément
mauvais parce que si ton citoyen un
moment donné s'endête par exemple pour
s'acheter une baraque parce qu'il peut
plus l'acheter autrement et que tout
d'un coup il y a un craque comme il y a
eu aux États-Unis, ça peut par un effet
de de répercussion devenir une crise
économique bien plus importante. Donc
voilà pour pour te dire je ne suis pas
affelé par la question du déficit en
France, je suis affelé de ce qu'on en
fait, c'est autre chose. Et je ne crois
pas aux oiseaux de mauvais augure qui
nous disent que au nom du déficit, on
risque d'être en faillite. Ça fait des
décennies. Te rappelles Fillon, il avait
déjà dit ça. On n jamais été en faillite
depuis et puis en réalité
il avait peut-être des informations que
tu n'avais pas.
Bah la preuve que non puisquon a pas été
en faillite d'ailleurs.
On a fait 1000 milliards de dettes en
plus.
Oui oui ça d'accord. Et juste alors
justement on a fait 1000 milliards. Il y
a une partie 1000 milliards c'est la
dette Covid. Bon, qui a touché 200
milliards.
Ouais, c'est ça. Qu'il a touche autre
chose, c'est que
200 milliards.
Oui, mais alors c'est justement c'est
une dette. C'est une dette. Ayons ça en
tête. La dette Covid, elle a une
particularité hein. Elle est pas sur les
marchés.
La dette Covid c'est une exception qui a
été décidée par la Banque centrale
européenne contre ses traités. La Banque
centrale européenne sur situation
exceptionnelle a décidé de prêter
directement aux États par leur banque
centrale.
Donc c'est la dette COVID nous
appartient appartient à la banque
centrale. La banque centrale c'est elle
qui est dernier acteur. C'est ça
juste oui et donc c'est pas les marchés.
Donc tu n'es pas soumis à la pression
des marchés. Tu peux par exemple moi
j'étais pour annuler cette dette.
Voilà je pense qu'il aurait Ouais. Ça
aurait produit un peu plus d'inflation.
Bon voilà, un petit peu d'inflation
parce qu'on aurait produit quand à nul
dette d'inflation.
Bon, à l'époque, on avait calculé que ça
pouvait produire 03 04 points
d'inflation. Bon, alors après, tu te
regardes, est-ce que c'est mieux d'avoir
03 04 points d'inflation à ce moment-là
que d'avoir une espèce de d'épé de dame
classe sur les États pendant des
décennies en disant vous devez
rembourser ces dettes. Et dans
l'histoire, il y a eu des remboursements
de dette. Je te rappelle, l'Allemagne a
été sa dette a été annulée après guerre.
On oublie de le dire. Bon, donc c'était
pas complètement à considérer. Et ce qui
est intéressant, c'est que comme la
dette appartienait aux banques
centrales, là tu peux annuler la dette
ou tu peux la reporter ou tu peux la
renégocier. Bon, donc euh je trouve
intéressant que la dette Covid a été
faite comme ça parce que c'est des
pistes pour la suite et notamment c'est
une piste qui est discutée en ce moment,
figure-toi, par qui ? C'est par Dragy.
Dragy vient de produire
Super Mario.
Ouais. Vient de produire un rapport.
Oui, mais d'accord. Mais moi ça
m'intéresse. Tu sais pourquoi je dis
Super Mario ?
Non. par rapport au jeu.
Non, pas par il distribuait un peu comme
Ben Bernank du pognon du pognon du
pognon du pognon du pognon
turbon. Enfin bon, c'est pas ma tasse de
drag, mais ça m'intéresse quand même que
quelqu'un du système dise aujourd'hui
que le système actuel, il est à bout de
souffle et qui manque 600 milliards
d'investissements en Europe et qu'il
faudrait peut-être arrêter que l'Europe
se bâtisse avant tout sur la
concurrence, mais plutôt essayer de voir
comment à un moment donné tu concentres
l'investissement
justement pour permettre à la fois
ça c'est pas un douf, on n pas la même
langue. Regarde les Allemands, ils nous
ont tiré dans les pattes avec si je
pense. Comment ?
Non non, sur l'Europe c'est un dou rêve.
C'est un dou rêve,
je te te le dis.
Ah bah
voilà, mais l'idée qu'à un moment donné,
il va falloir dégager des marches pour
investir euh ça c'est pas un dou rêve,
ça c'est la réalité. C'est
une autre question. Alors c'est
peut-être pas de ton de tes capacités,
non pas intellectuelles, mais de tes
capacités pour aller chercher
l'information.
La Banque centrale européenne derrière
ces beaux murs, ces belles façades,
est-ce que l'intérieur c'est pas un peu
un tait avec des obligues toutes
dégueulasses ?
et que ça tient par le bout du fil. Non,
je sais pas ça. Tu
as bien une petite idée ?
Non, non, j'ai pas d'idée. Non, j'ai pas
l'impression.
Non, j'ai pas l'impression. C'est une
banque centrale
qui qui a qui a un gros défaut, c'est
qu'elle est indépendante du pouvoir
politique. Ça pour moi, c'est un
problème. Mais non,
on a préparé un deuxième micro au cas où
si celui là lâche. D'ailleurs, il faudra
lui mettre un coup de tournevis les
gars. Non, non, touche pas. Merci bien.
Revenons. Revenons.
Tu es tu es tu es réactif quand même.
C'est bien. Revenons à à nos idées de
finances. Euh tu connais Yanis
Varoufakis qui était assis sur ce siège
euh il y a 2 3 ans. On lui passe le
bonjour aussi.
Tu as pas l'impression aussi que pour
mettre un peuple en esclavage, c'est
mieux de lui faire la dette de lui
mettre de la dette plutôt que de lui
faire de la guerre. De la lui faire la
guerre. Est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression qu'il y a une upper classe,
une classe super haute haute au-dessus
de tout le monde à Patride
qui est en train de mettre tous les
états endettés et ensuite ils vont venir
en disant bah là ton petit portartient
ça on va le vendre puis tu vas bosser
beaucoup plus puis ta retraite on va te
la à on va te la mettre à 75 ans
et puis et puis toi tu es ouvrier bah
ton espérance de vie bah c'est pas grave
puis tu es plus fatigué bon c'est pas
grave Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Je
grossis le trait. Je fais exprès de
grossir le trait.
Non non non, tu mais tu Ça c'est la
c'est ce que je te disais tout à
l'heure, mais tu as pas besoin forcément
vis-à-vis d'un pays comme la France
d'avoir un d'avoir un scénario à la
Grèce
à la Grec.
À la Grec, pas de FM.
Non, tu peux avoir un autre scénario
mais qui est en train de se construire.
Et ben
tu fais de la dette un problème le
problème majeur de ton de ton économie.
Tu dis c'est horrible. Au nom de la
dette, faut baisser les dépenses
publiques. Si tu baisses les dépenses
publiques, les dépenses sociales à un
moment donné,
ce qui te permettait à nos concitoyens
de se soigner,
de s'éduquer,
de prendre leur retraite, si le public
est plus capable de leur rassurer parce
que tu vas tellement descendre les
prestations
que elle va plus avoir de sens,
qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Ceux qui ont les
moyens, tu le prends au niveau du privé
et donc tu vas le prendre sur des
assurances, des opérations de crédit et
cetera. Autrement dit, ta vente à la
découpe au privé, tu l'organises comme
ça. La Grèce a été par un raid
qui a forcé la Grèce à vendre ses bijoux
de famille. D'accord. La France, ça peut
être une méthode plus douce qui est
y compris faite par les Français
eux-mêmes en terme politique qui est
d'organiser
la privatisation
de tes services publics au nom de la
baisse des dépenses publiques. C'est
comme ça que ça s'organise. Et donc là,
c'est ce que je te disais. Quand je te
disais les Pays-Bas, il faut regarder la
dette privée des Pays-Bas. Là, ça sera
la dette privée qui va augmenter parce
que pour faire ça, tu vas avoir un
endettement. Il y a ceux qui pourront se
le payer, puis il y a ceux qui vont
s'endetter pour se le payer. Mais c'est
la même chose. C'est-à-dire que tu as
euh des entreprise, des boîtes, le
domaine privé qui va s'emparer de ce qui
est rentable, ce qui jusqu'à maintenant
était était géré par le par le public.
C'est exactement la même chose.
Revenons. Revenons encore à la à la fin.
Je suis clair ou pas ?
Écoute, ça m'a l'air intéressant.
OK, d'accord.
Ça, de toute façon, si c'était pas
clair, tu te feras secouer sur internet.
Tu me déconcentres, c'est pas sympa de
faire ça.
Revenons à la dette, revenons au budget,
revenons à la Grèce. Est-ce qu'il y a
pas trop de fonctionnaires en France ?
Est-ce qu'on a pas fait du
fonctionnariat un peu de la subordnation
de vote en disant "T'inquiète, vote pour
moi, tu auras ton petit emploi de
cantonnier, t'inquiète, vote pour moi."
Ou je ne vais pas baisser la retraite
des fonctionnaires, je vais pas Est-ce
qu'il y a pas trop de fonctionnaires ?
Est-ce qu'il y a pas trop de
fonctionnaires en France ? Est-ce que le
volume de fonctionnaires depuis les 30
dernières années, il a pas explosé ?
Est-ce que par si est-ce que nos
fonctionnaires politiques,
quand on voit le nombre de politiciens
en Allemagne, il y en a deux ou trois
fois moins, je demande à me faire fa
checker. Quand on voit le nombre de
politiciens, ce qui nous coûte, ce qui
s'augmente. Nos sénateurs, ils sont
augmentés de combien là déjà pour 700
balles ? Non,
je sais pas.
Tu sais pas toi, tu t'es augmenté de
combien ? On a Non, on n pas augmenté.
Non 300
non non non non non non
non pas 300 € non clarifie les 300 €
c'est pas nos revenus c'est qu'on a on a
un revenu des indemnités à côté de ça on
a une enveloppe de frais qui est
euh qui est à 2000 de 5000 € par mois.
Oui mais d'accord
c'est c'est pour distribuer au manon.
Attends pas du tout. Tu payes ta
permanence.
D'accord. Moi ma permanence
elle est à B les Bruyers
hein.
Elle est à Bécon les brouillères.
Non, elle est à Saint-toi. Ma permanence
elle me coûte avec électricité tout ça.
Toi, elle doit me coûter 1600 € par mois
déjà. tu payes tes déplacements,
tu payes euh tous tes frais de
déplacement qui sont importants, tu
payes exactement ce que je paye
quelqu'un qui est dans une boîte et qui
à un moment donné va tous ces frais
professionnels, ces frais induits par
son boulot, les sont payés par les
boîtes. Enfin, moi je quand j'étais chef
d'entreprise, mes frais de boulot
étaient payés par des frais, c'est la
même chose et c'est sur justif, ça peut
pas être de tout à ce que je veux dire.
Et alors, j'ouvre une parenthèse sur ces
frais de de
parce qu' oublie pas non attends je veux
juste revenir à autre chose pour bien
comprendre parce que le bashing sur les
élus je m'en méfie beaucoup pas ce que
tu fais mais oublie jamais une chose
c'est que un élu un député euh c'est un
petit chef d'entreprise puisqu'il a un
cabinet autour de lui. Il a trois
collaborateurs minimum. Moi j'en ai deux
fois plus que je suis président de la
commission des finances.
Tu les payes pas ? Tu les payes deux
fois moins ?
Non ils sont Non non pas du tout. Non,
j'ai une enveloppe supplémentaire parce
que il y a plus de boulot en tant que la
commission d'idence. Je peux t'assurer
qu'il bosse beaucoup. Et donc
combien tu les payes ?
Euh bah tu as une enveloppe de en gros
tu as une enveloppe de près de 10000 €
pour tr qu personnes.
Donc tu les payes combien ?
Bah ça fait calcul. Si toi tu j'en ai
10000 j'en ai tr ça fait 3000 € chacun.
Tu as les mêmes cotisations, les mêmes
charges
quasiment. Ouais, ouais, ouais. Enfin,
mais ça les charges pas moi qui les
paye. C'est assuré par le par
l'assemblée. Les charges patronales,
hein. La part des patronales, c'est pas
moi qui paye. Ce qui est pris dans le
dans les c'est les charges en gros
salariés qui sont pris dans ces 10000 €.
Mais ce que je veux te dire par là,
c'est que tu produis une activité autour
de toi qui est une activité de chef
d'entreprise. Donc, inévitablement, tu
as des frais professionnels et c'est ces
preuves professionnels qui ont été
augmentés de 300 €. Alors, on peut
trouver que c'est pas normal, hein. Moi,
j'avais rien demandé. D'accord. Mais je
veux dire par là par contre nos
indemnités ont pas été augmenté depuis
des années. Je le précise quand même.
Tu t'es jamais abonné à un site de
rencontre avec ton indemnité ?
Tu as jamais acheté de stupéfiant avec
ton indemnité ?
Non mais d'ailleurs pour l'instant aucun
député l'a fait.
Non non.
C'est quoi cette histoire que il y en a
Andarbrat ? Si tu parles de de Handy
Carbrat, il il nit absolument avoir
acheté des stupéfiants avec ce FM.
Alors, je pense qu'il y aura une enquête
donc on le saura mais lui il le voil
pourquoi les les médias sortent ça ?
Écoute, demande au médias pour qu'ils le
sortent. Mais parce que ils ont ils ont
subodoré parce que je suis pas rentré
dans la vie d'Andy qui est en plus
actuellement en cure et qui est malade,
il se soigne,
il se soigne voilà de toi parce qu'il a
il a des addictions, il les reconnaît,
voilà. bon euh forte. Euh donc il se
soigne et il a une vie qui est qui est
qui est compliquée mais il il nous il
assure qu'il a pas payé euh ses
stupéfiants avec la FM et moi je veux le
croire. Voilà si s'il y a une enquête
qui prouve l'inverse, on en parlera à ce
pointlà mais pour l'instant je veux le
croire. Enfin bon non je ne fais pas
tout ça. Non pour être clair
tuachètes pas de cigar
non plus. Non non, je je n'achète pour
être clair, mon AFM sert exactement à
payer ce que en tant que député je
n'aurais pas payé. J'aurais pas payé si
j'étais pas député pour plein de
raisons. Voilà, c'est tout.
Quand tu fais un resto avec
Si c'est un resto professionnel, c'est
mon AFM. Si c'est un resto privé, c'est
pas mon tout chef d'entreprise qui
reçoit des clients qui négocie des
marchés autour de d'une assiette. Tu
prends le ticket
bien sûr et je dois et je suis contrôlé.
C'est bien.
Voilà. C'est bien.
On est contrôlé par le déontologue.
Moi, j'ai déjà été contrôlé deux fois.
J'ai un expert comptable.
Que tu payes combien ?
Euh, je je suis désolé, je me je on a
une enveloppe, je m'en veux pas, mais ça
doit être en gros 1500 € dans l'année,
quelque chose comme ça. Mais je peux me
tromper là-dessus.
Tu as un compte à l'étranger ?
Non, c'est interdit.
Tu as une mine d'or.
C'est interdit.
C'est Ah bon ? C'est bien
depuis l'affaire Kusac.
Non, non, c'est c'est interdit. Tu sais
qu'on est des personnes, tu sais, on
fait partie des personnes
qui doivent montrer l'exemple. Non non
non, c'est pas ça. On est euh un élu et
sa famille et c'est ça va même jusqu'à
mon père pour te dire sont des personnes
considérées par les banques comme des
personnes euh j'ai j'ai excuse-moi, j'ai
plus le terme enfin en gros, on nous on
nous surveille euh de manière attentive
chaque année. Je remplis un
questionnaire sur tout ce que j'ai et
cetera. Ce que je
encore heureux. Non, j'ai
Est-ce que je te dis l'inverse ?
Bon mais oui, encore heureux.
Oui, tu as raison. Encore heureux. Je
trouve que des fois ça va un peu loin
quand ça va sur tes enfants et autres.
Mais bon,
je comprends pourquoi ?
Oui, je comprends pourquoi. Oui, parce
que parce que des parce que il y a eu
des choses qui ont été faites qui sont
pas normales. Bien sûr,
mais je te on a on a la haute autorité
de transparence qui chaque année fait
que tu dois faire un un ta déclaration
de patrimoine, ta déclaration de revenu
de manière extrêmement précise.
Quand tu oublies par exemple que tu as
300000 € d'action dans pétrolière, c'est
un problème que je te dise mais moi
j'aurais pas ça donc j'ai pas d'action.
Donc
c'est quoi ton patrimoine ?
Je j'ai euh 40 % euh de mon appart à
Paris dans lequel je vis avec ma femme.
Ta femme à 60 %.
Emmerde pas ta femme mettre dehors sinon
hein.
Non, c'est qu'elle a c'est qu'elle avait
elle a eu elle elle a eu un un héritage
que moi je n'ai jamais eu. Enfin
pratiquement voilà mon patrimoine c'est
ça principal et et c'est un dernier
étage avec terrasse 55 millions d'euros.
Ah non non non. Mais c'est un
appartement parisien. Donc un
appartement parisien acheté à un moment
où le marché était très bas à Paris, il
a de la il a une certaine valeur.
Combien ?
Oh écoute, moi je pense que mon
patrimoine doit être environ de 400000
€.
Tu as du cash ?
Non.
Une mine d'or au Yana ?
Non, j'ai rien. Tu
as même pas de relaxe. Tu as raté ta vie
?
Non, j'ai pas raté ma vie. Ça va, je vis
correctement.
J'ai j'ai des revenus je trouve qui sont
euh euh qui sont euh
J'arrête de t'emmerder. Non, non, mais
je te dis mais je voudrais juste dire
une chose quand même pour être clair.
Euh mon et je pleure pas parce que je
voulais être élu, je voulais être
député, c'était le mandat que je
voulais. Mais tu as compris que
tu aurais pu te faire plus de blé dans
le privé. Attends, attends. Non, mon
activité politique m'a coûté du blé
quand je travaill dans le privé parce
que c'est jamais forcé d'être facile de
travailler dans le privé et d'être connu
comme un militant y compris un militant
de gauche, c'est plutôt la gauche
radicale. Donc ça m'a plutôt coûté de
l'argent pour dire. Mais euh
moi j'ai bossé, j'ai commencé à bosser à
18 ans et j'ai bossé toute ma vie. Bon,
donc là, j'ai accepté et et j'ai une
idée, j'ai une vision de la politique
qui est très claire. Je pense que la
politique ne doit jamais être une
carrière. Jamais. Ça doit jamais être un
métier. Je refuse l'idée que tu vives de
la politique toute ta vie.
Pourquoi je refuse ça ? Parce que je
pense que si tu vis de la politique
toute ta vie, tes conditions matérielles
au bout d'un moment l'emportent sur tes
idées. D'accord ? Donc moi voilà, c'est
quelque chose auquel je m'reins
sur un certain nombre de mandailles. Je
pense par exemple que un politique ne
devrait pas pouvoir faire plus un élu ne
devrait pas pouvoir faire plus de de
trois mandats maximum.
Je sais que je dois te lâcher d'ici une
demi-heure. Ça fait 1h25 qu'on est en
direct. Je peux gratter 15 minutes ou
pas ou tu es vraiment charrette ?
Je suis un peu charrette mais allons-y,
continuons. Je te je te réponds juste
là-dessus, c'est mon mon truc. Donc pour
te dire là par exle mon revenu, moi j'ai
jamais gagné aussi bien ma vie hein.
Mais je travaille enfin travailler comme
c'est pas un métier, on va dire mon
activité de député me prend 80 heures
par semaine.
Voilà,
c'est de l'esclavage.
Non, c'est pas de l'esclavage, c'est
juste pour relativiser mes indemnités.
Peut-être que tu sais pas t'organiser.
Si si, je crois au contraire, je sais
bien. Sinon, je pourrais pas faire
autant de choses. Mais c'est juste, tu
vois, pour qu'on est que les gens qui
m'écoute sache quand même que
globalement pour aller vite, on veul pas
notre indignité quoi. Si je me compare,
mon indignité est bien moindre que le
revenu d'un cadre supérieur dans une
boîte par exemple.
Comment t'explique toute cette défiance
par rapport aux élus ?
Peut-être qu'ils l'ont mérité. Peut-être
qu'il a peut-être que certains l'ont
mérité. Il y a eu des affaires
absolument anormales de collusion, de
voilà. Donc moi je peux je comprends et
que après on ne peut nous croire que sur
parole. Je veux dire quand quand tu vois
moi je me suis pas enrichi de mon mon
boulot d'élu enfin de mon mais bon voilà
il y a eu il y a eu des abus il y a eu
tout ça. Bon il y a aussi un un jeu
national il y a aussi quelque part
peut-être certains qui pratiquent aussi
une espèce d'antiparlementarisme. Donc
faut faire un peu attention là-dessus.
Je vais prendre une question internet.
Euh
je sais c'est pas c'est c'est c'est une
question qui est provoque d'ailleurs. Ah
un fan d'interdiction nouvelle
devrait-on interdire de se revendiquer
communiste ?
Bah non.
Est-ce que tu as une opinion sur le
Bitcoin ?
Non, j'ai pas spécialement d'opinion. Je
Et le fait que je pense que commencer
une réserve stratégique
que ça soit Bitcoin, que soit crypto et
cetera. Je pense que c'est des sources à
spéculation euh et à et à euh toute une
finance qui est euh toujours plus hors
de contrôle. C'est en ça que je me
méfie.
Comment tu vois l'arrivée de Trump ?
Bah comme une je la vois comme la la
marque de l'extrême droitisation
aujourd'hui des des
euh des pays libéraux
et et c'est pas apparu comme ça. C'est
c'est c'est
c'est un cours qui est pris.
C'est à cause de quoi ? parce qu'on voit
la même chose en Europe.
Alors pourquoi pourquoi
je vais revenir un peu à mon analyse. On
a un capitalisme si on a bien compris ce
que qui est
qui est ce que j'appellerai un hard
capitalisme
c'est-à-dire qui a tendance
sa tendance c'est de considérer que
absolument toutes les sphères de
l'activité humaine
doivent être soumis aux règles du marché
du profit et que ce profit n'a pas de
limite. C'est ça sa tendance. Il y a une
vision absolutiste du capitalisme et
inévitablement ce capitalisme là alors
que pendant des décennies le capitalisme
a été l'idée l'image du capitalisme a
été adossée à la question de la
démocratie libérale. Ça c'était assez
lié. On parlait même de démocratie
bourgeoise. Je pense que le terme est un
très mauvais terme. Cit moi je suis
revenu de tout ça, je suis plutôt
joricien dans dans sur sur la question
de la citoyenneté et cetera. Donc je
pense que les démocraties c'est
important les démocraties
représentatives. N'empêche pendant très
longtemps, on a pensé que le capitalisme
était lié avec ça. Et ce capitalisme là,
il est tellement absolutisme que à un
moment donné pour continuer à exercer sa
domination, pour continuer à exercer des
politiques toujours plus inégale, et
bien il doit être il emprunte à
l'autoritarisme ses ses recettes et il
compris il emprunte à l'extrême droite,
y compris ses ses recettes de façon on
va diviser le peuple à de faç par le
racisme de façon à à asseoir une
domination par des mesures toujours plus
autoritaires illibérales. Et c'est en ça
que je pense que le devenir de ce
capitalist, si on si on n met pas fin de
ce capitalisme là, j'entends bien, je
pense qu'il y a une dérive totalitaire
même à terme dans ce capitalisme là. et
quelque part des gens comme Trump, des
gens comme Orban, des gens comme
Bolsonaro dont la caractéristique c'est
que ils ne viennent pas de l'extrême
droite organisé, c'était des néolibéraux
mais n'empêche ils pratiquent une
politique s'apparente toujours plus à
une espèce de néofascisme. Voilà donc
pour te dire, je vois avec inquiétude le
retour de Trump.
Est-ce qu'il faut sortir de l'Europe
parce que le
sans parler de son caractère écosidaire
qui est vraiment très inquiétant.
On va revenir à au caractère écosidaire.
Après, tu me laisses pas beaucoup de
temps. Tu es difficile avec moi
aujourd'hui, euh revenons à l'Europe, à
l'euro avec tous ces petits pays qui se
tirent dans les pattes face un gros bloc
américain, un gros bloc chinois avec une
guerre par proxy en Europe avec nous au
milieu et puis on se fait découper en
morceaux parce que ça fait gagner du
temps, ça fait gagner des marchés à
Pierre l'Américain et à Jean Jean-Louis
le chinois. Ouais, comme ça on se fait
bien on se fait bien ouvrir en deux.
Est-ce que il faut pas faire comme le
général de Gaulle un peu faire bon
maintenant ça suffit les gars Frexite on
s'arrache, on récupère notre monnaie, on
évalue un coup de notre monnaie, on
devient plus compétitif, on remet les
choses en place, on on récupère notre
parole diplomatique, on dit à l'autant
"Bon maintenant, tu vas aller te faire
brosser un petit peu parce que bon, tu
as les mêmes astrologues qu'on a à Ber
?"
Bien sûr que oui.
Frexite ? Non, pasite, mais euh sur
l'OTAN, bien sûr que oui.
On sort de l'OTAN.
Ah bah oui, moi je suis pour sortir
comment pour se défendre face aux gros
Chinois et aux gros Américains, aux gros
russes ? Bah
tu as l'impression que les Américains
nous défendent de défendent nos
intérêts. Toi, tu as l'impression que
dans le monde les Américains défendent
nos intérêts.
Oui. La main sur le cœur des écoles pour
les petites filles, démocr je crois
beaucoup à
Tu es antiaméricain Eric. Non, je pas
antiaméricain mais je mais tu sais moi
je suis un j'ai un peu des classiques.
L'impérialisme américain me je pense est
l'impérialisme le plus dangereux au
monde, même si des fois il a des il a
des aspects un peu plus sympathiques que
certains pays plus totalitaire on va
dire dans he Oui, bien sûr.
Mais dans ses formes de domination, il
est extrêmement dangereux sur on va dire
sa voraité par rapport à des marchés par
rapport
par rapport aux matières premières par
rapport domination. Donc il est pas il
est monsieur pour être très clair, je
pense pas que l'impérialisme américain
soit moins dangereux que l'impérialisme
de monsieur Poutine ou l'impérialisme
chinois. Je sais que ça va faire bondir
quand je dis ça parce que je vois bien
que le système de Poutine son côté
agressif en ce moment vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine euh
mais les Américains le font d'une autre
manière. D'accord ? Ils le font d'une
autre forme.
C'est qu'ils font des révolutions de
couleur
hein.
Ils font des révolutions de couleurs,
des révolutions colorées.
Ça peut arriver. Mais je vais revenir
sur ce que Attends, je vais revenir
parce que sinon je vais sauter le
collègue. Je vais pas dire moi je suis
pour une politique indépendantiste.
Je suis pour que la France est une
politique indépendantiste. Je suis pour
que la France continue à avoir une
stratégie nationale et cetera et cetera.
Ça ne veut pas dire, et c'est pour ça
que je ne suis pas pour le Frexit, ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on essaie pas d'avoir
des coopérations au niveau de l'Europe
notamment pour pouvoir justement à un
moment donné contrebalancer
ces différents impérialismes par une
autre politique, mais ça ne peut se
faire que si l'Europe est source d'un
progrès social et écologique. Si c'est
juste un espace de libre échange qui
permet en en un espèce de dumping fiscal
social généralisé et qui enrichit
toujours les mêmes en jouant sur le fait
tu vois ce que je veux dire. Voilà donc
je je te répond pas tu vois ce que je
veux dire à chaque fois de phrase s'il
te plaît. Bah
excuse-moi c'est une forme de tu as
raison c'est peut-être pas terrible mais
c'est un type de langage que je trouve
que je trouve tout à fait bon chacun ses
thqu je merci.
Revenons à On se retrouve dans des
guerres par proxy. On se retrouve dans
une nouvelle guerre froide avec des
stratégies de guerre froide.
C'est-à-dire tu m'embêtes là, je t'ouvre
un autre conflit ailleurs. Tu vois ce
qui se passe avec la Syrie et ainsi de
suite. Tu vois ce qui se passe avec le
Hamas, le esbola. Je te fournis des
armes, je me fais un peu de blé, ça
t'ennuie et on continue à sacrifier des
orges sur le terrain. Il y a des jeunes
Ukrainiens qui se font fracassés. Il y a
des jeunes russes qui se font fracassés,
des prolétaires en général qui se font
fracasser pour je dirais du capital.
Comment on fait pour arrêter tout ça
avec une fonction exponentielle de
croissance mondiale, de consommation de
ressources, de consommation de de
matière première, d'énergie avec un
gâteau qui rétrécit comme pot de chagrin
et qui accentue et qui accentue les
tensions entre ces gros blocs pour
l'hégémonie de Pierre, l'hégémonies de
Jacques, les gémonies de de Yuri,
l'hégémonie de ce que tu veux,
de Pedro et j'en passé des meilleurs. Je
pense que c'est plus un problème de
système que de gens.
C'est un problème de système. Sauf qu'il
y a des gens.
Alors comment on fait ? Comment on fait
? Euh
déjà déjà moi je tu parlais de guerre
froide, je crois pas que ça soit la
bonne comparaison.
Quelle est la bonne comparaison ?
La bonne comparaison c'est avant la
guerre 14. Voilà. La guerre la guerre de
Oui, bien sûr. Je pense que la guerre
tu vois la boucherie qui a qui a sur Bah
je vois la boucherie de la première
guerre, je vois la crise économique de
29 et je vois la deuxème guerre.
D'accord.
Par quoi est déclenchée la Première
Guerre mondiale ? Elle est déclenchée
par la première mondialisation
capitaliste,
c'est-à-dire le fait que à une échelle
planétaire, les blocs d'alors
s'affrontent exactement comme sont en
train de s'affronter les blocs pour
exact le le le pour j'allais dire départ
de marché des profits toujours plus
importants. La garde 14, elle est issue
de ça. Si on l'oublie, on comprend pas.
Et nous sommes là dans cette période
une histoire avec François Ferdinand là.
Oui, mais ça c'est d'accord mais ça
c'est l'élément qui à un moment donné
fait que tout d'un coup tu tu euh tu
avais un baril de poudre et tu mets le
le fil mais ton baril de poudre il était
là. D'accord. Je pense que nous sommes
exactement dans cette période et je
pense même, je vais te dire un truc,
c'est que euh s'il y avait pas l'arme de
dissuasion, il y a longtemps que nous
serions aujourd'hui dans une guerre
mondiale, je pense en réalité comme il y
a l'arme nucléaire, c'est ce qui tend un
peu à faire en sorte que il y ait pas eu
encore une confrontation. Donc la
confrontation, elle est sur euh, on va
dire des euh des des étages secondaires.
C'est on va se confronter en Ukraine, on
va se confronter et cetera. Bon, mais je
pense qu'on est sur cette question.
Alors face quand je te dis ça, ça montre
bien la gravité. Surtout qu'on a ajouté
un autre élément par rapport à à cette
période là, c'est qu'on a ajouté
l'urgence climatique et écologique hein.
Et donc comme on fait ? Moi, je n'ai pas
d'autres réponse que le fait que on doit
essayer
dans certains pays et la France en fait
partie parce qu'elle continue à être
regardée dans le monde
de moins en moins.
Non non, la alors tu as raison après 7
ans de Macron de moins en moins, ça
c'est sûr. Mais
on vient on vient de se faire bouter de
raison. Tu as raison
de moins en moins. N'empêche quand même.
Moi ce que j'observe quand je vais dans
d'autres pays du monde,
lesquels ? Ah bah euh quand tu vas, y
compris quand tu vas parle qu'en
Afrique, je sais pas quoi vous êtes de
là, quand tu vas en Amérique latine,
quand tu parles à Loula par exemple, la
France que fait la France est très
regardée. Par exemple, le fait qu'en
France
il y a eu en 2022 le fait que pour la
première fois c'est la gauche radicale
qui est devenue majoritaire à gauche sur
un projet de transformation s regardé
par les autres pays du monde. Et donc
moi ma seule solution, j'ai pas d'autres
solutions à te donner, c'est le fait
qu'à un moment donné il y a un pays et
qu'après il y en ait plein d'autres
peut-être par exemple ton micro s'il te
plaît
peut-être par l'exemple qui est fait
qu'on arrive à transformer la donne dans
un de ces pays. J'ai pas d'autres
solution.
Et alors Loua, il a pas dit à à Macron,
je me je demande à me faire fa checker,
il a pas dit bon écoute Macron, tu es
gentil avec le Mercour, mais c'est
Angela qui va qui va décider pour toi,
donc tu peux t'asseoir.
Je suis pas sûr que Loua ait ce genre de
discours.
C'est pas Loua, c'était qui ?
He
donc là le mercour, on fait quoi ? Bah
nous on est pour euh nous on a refusé de
voter l'autre jour à l'Assemblée parce
que l'idée c'était de dire on n'accepte
pas le mercour en l'état mais on
continue à négocier. On se retient.
OK. Et qui est-ce qui va décider ? C'est
pas l'Europe.
Alors justement, il y a un débat
actuellement pour
pour sortir de l'Europe.
Non, il y a un débat actuellement pour
dire que il peut pas y avoir une
décision sur la majorité qualifiée, mais
que il doit y avoir une unanimité des
pays de l'Europe et que nous, moi je
milite pour que la France ne fasse pas
partie de ça. Et donc à partir de là, il
y aura pas de mercour. La bataille est
pas perdue de ce point de vue-là.
Commentaire sur internet.
Sérieusement, l'argument du salaire
différé, c'est une blague pour les PME.
Entre parenthèses, ici, je suis en
frontal avec le Luxembourg. Fermez la
parenthèse. Les luxembourgeois chiffrent
moins cher que moi et payent mieux leur
gars. Je fais quoi moi ?
Je sais pas ce que fait le c'est un chef
d'entreprise.
Moi, c'est ce que j'ai dit hier à la
CGPME. Il y a la France,
elle par an, il y a à peu près 211
milliards d'aide aux entreprises.
Voilà, en Europe,
c'est les assister.
Non, pas du tout. C'est pas que je vais
dire. Il y a 211 milliards d'aides aux
entreprises globalement en comptant les
exonérations de cotisation là-dedans.
C'est beaucoup, c'est le record en
Europe. Donc moi, je suis pour que
on est on enquête sur ces aides aides
publiques aux entreprises. Est-ce que
c'est normal qu'on aide pareillment une
multinationale qui va utiliser une
partie de ses aides pour les
redescriribuer en dividende et que je ne
sais pas qui, mais par exemple la
personne dont tu me parles, on l'aide
pas plus pour pouvoir résister à à la
délocalisation des concurrences
nationales. Moi, je suis pour orienter
les aides de cette façonlà de façon et
je suis aussi je vais continuer et je
suis pour des mesures protectionnistes
aussi qui protègent les entreprises
françaises. Voilà. Donc je pense que ça
c'est une politique qui peut être mise
en place et la France a encore des
moyens de le faire.
Alors une question avec un commentaire
que je vais lire aussi. Quel est son
avis sur les dépenses de l'État ? On en
a déjà parlé mais je vais lire le
commentaire. Les dépenses de l'État
représentent 57 % de notre PIB, mais il
n'en parle pas une seconde et passe
directement sur les recettes.
Et ben alors déjà les recettes de juste
pour expliquer d'où il y a les déficits,
les dépenses de l'État par rapport au
PIB, elles ont elles ont baissé depuis
2017.
Voilà, de 2 %. C'est juste pour dire
pourquoi c'est pas ça qui a créé les
déficits supplémentaires et bien la
baisse des recettes et ben moi je suis
pas quel est le problème qui est alors
c'est pas que l'état c'est les dépenses
globales hein des collectivités autres
c'est aussi les dépenses de prestation
sociale. Moi je suis pas C'est quoi le
problème ? C'est quoi le problème ? Les
dépenses de l'État c'est produit des
recettes aussi et tu l' et je te l'ai
dit tout à l'heure si c'est pas l'état
qui dépense c'est pas les collectivités
c'est pas le public tes dépenses tu vas
aller les chercher dans le privé. Moi,
j'ai pas de problème que à un moment
donné l'État assure que dans sur
certains secteurs qui ont des besoins
fondamentaux, des biens communs, c'est
lui qui assure c'est cette mécanise de
solidarité. Et contrairement à ce qu'on
dit, c'est aussi source de recette. Tu
sais pourquoi la France est pas rentrée
en récession euh en 20090 ? Le marché
privé était à ton, il était en des C'est
le la dépense publique qui a permis de
de soutenir l'activité économique. Et tu
sais pourquoi l'an dernier l'Allemagne
est rentrée en récession ? Parce qu'en
Allemagne, ça va mal aussi actuellement.
D'accord. Pourquoi l'Allemagne est
rentrée en récession et pourquoi la
France n'est pas rentrée ? Parce que
justement en France, on a un matelas à
un moment donné de protection sociale,
de dépenses de l'État qui fait que
vaille que vaille, notre économie, elle
a un peu plus tenu la route
qui s'appellit la grosse dette.
Comment
qui s'appellerait la dette ?
Les Allemands veulent pas faire de
dette.
Oui, mais c'est un problème. D'ailleurs,
ils y reviennent. Tuas tu as marqué
qu'il y a un gros débat là-dessus chez
Scholâché que ça ministre ils ont un
débat. H
euh la coalition des trois est en train
de sauter. H
euh bon, c'est ça devient compliqué.
Mais oui, parce que c'est ce système là
qui est c'est le système allemand. Le
système quand on a fait l'euro quand on
a fait l'euro,
n'oublie jamais que en échange de faire
l'euro, les Allemands nous ont dit "OK,
on fait l'euro mais on l'aligne l'euro
sur le marque."
Bon, qu'est-ce que ça a produit ça ?
D'évaluer le faux marqu.
Alors, qu'est-ce que ça a produit ? Ça a
produit que on a une monnaie qui pour la
plupart des économies d'Europe était
beaucoup trop forte. Pourquoi elle a été
faite ? Parce que le système économique
allemand notamment en terme par exemple
de tout ce qui est retraite se base sur
des systèmes de capitalisation et de
rentier. Donc il faut pas que la monnaie
baisse et donc on a tous souffert de
cette politique monétariste
deolibéralisme
qui fait en sorte qu'on a une politique
de façon à à laisser la monnaie toujours
forte. Donc je te coupe et j'en profite
pour lire la question suivante. Il dit
que le système international nous amène
dans le mur. L'Union européenne est
construite pour défendre les intérêts
des grandes multinationales.
Influence des lobistes sur les
règlements européens. Quit du Frexit
pour reprendre le contrôle de nos
politiques économiques.
Je suis pas sûr que le Frexit est
vraiment avantagé la Grande-Bretagne,
donc je me méfie de ça.
Le Brexit.
Ouais. Et moi je suis je suis pas euh je
suis pas pour laisser l'Europe à
l'Allemagne, quoi. C'est-à-dire que euh
moi j'étais prêt à laisser la France à
moi je suis je suis écoute-moi bien
c'est moi qui avais imaginé pour le
parti de gauche le plan A plan B.
D'accord. C'était après la crise
grecque. Pour ça que je connais bien
Varoufakis parce que Varoufakis au
moment où il y avait le la crise en
Grèce avait dit le problème c'est qu'on
a pas de plan B. Et c'est à ce moment-là
que moi j'avais fait une note qui
s'appelait pour un sem internationaliste
du plan B parce que j'avais considéré
que
Cypras quand il a négocié n'avait pas de
plan B. Le plan B c'est qui te permet de
faire autrement si à un moment donné en
face ça pas et je pense que le plan B
pour la Grèce à l'époque ça aurait été
carrément de sortir de l'Euro vu la
situation de la Grèce vu que son PIB est
à peu près égal au PIB de la
région-defance je pense qu'elle n'avait
pas le poids suffisant pour avoir imposé
rapport de France. Moi ce que je
défendais à ce moment-là, c'était dire
que le plan B pour la France, ça serait
très certainement de dire s'il y a
quelque chose qui nous convient pas, qui
est contraire par exemple au mandat qui
peut être le nôtre en France, et bien
nous désobissons. On fait ce qu'on
appelle l'optot. On sort à un moment
donné de certains de certains aspects du
traité si ces traités ne nous satisfont
pas. Autrement dit, on dit on sort pas
de l'eau, on sort pas de l'Europe, on
laisse pas l'Europe à l'Allemagne, mais
on dit que on est prêt à désobéir sur
certains aspects euh qui peuvent être
très vastes pour appliquer notre pro
politique. Puis on verra bien qui à ce
moment-là nous sortira la France parce
que chacun sait qu'en réalité l'Europe
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui, elle peut
pas se construire sans le de la deuxième
puissance économique de l'Europe est
bientôt le pays le plus peuplé. Ce n'est
pas vrai. Et donc moi je je pense que
par l'Allemagne là,
tu parles de l'Allemagne ? Non, c'est la
France. Bientôt, le pays le plus peuplé,
c'est la France. 2è puissance
économique, c'est la c'est la France,
l'Allemagne. Je veux dire par là que
c'est pas vrai de considérer. Donc je
pense que on peut avoir un rapport de
force pour changer les la donne en
Europe. À partir du moment où on dit une
chose, ce qui ne nous convient pas, ce
qui ne correspond pas à ce que au mandat
que le peuple français nous a donné, on
ne l'appliquera pas. C'est une politique
de désobéissance.
Non mais déjà, tu as eu du mal à faire
toc toc à la porte de Ber crois que tu
vas pouvoir faire la même chose avec
l'Europe ? gouverne pas.
Et quand si un jour vous gouvernez
et ben si un jour vous gouverne à
l'inverse de ce qu' a fait Hollande ou
ce qu' a fait Macron qui se sont
toujours pliés par rapport nous on dira
on n'est pas d'accord on le fait pas.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Quand il quand
ils t'ont fermé la porte au nez à Bery,
tu as fait quoi ? Tu as mis le pied dans
la porte ? Tu as gueulé, tu as appelé
Bruno, tu as dit bon maintenant faut
arrêter vos bêtises.
Non, on a pris bon on a des
fonctionnaires en face de nous de toute
façon en plus en plein gouvernement des
missionnaires mais on on a pris acte et
en disant que
parti avec la que entre les gens quoi.
Oh c'est pas une image. J'ai pas eu
l'impression qu'on soit reparti comme
ça. J'ai l'impression que ça a plutôt
valorisé euh le travail qu'on était en
train de faire et puis ça nous a pas
empêché après d'avoir les documents plus
tard les documents en question et tu
marqué ça m'empêche pas de mener la
bataille budgétaire à l'assemblée et de
d'essayer de faire en sorte que le
gouvernement tombe. Donc quira qui rira
rira bien le dernier.
Pas mal. Il nous reste
13 minutes.
Ouais.
Je peux gratter un peu plus ou tu es
vraiment charrette donc
tu vas revenir ? Oui, bien sûr.
Bon, parce que ça ça c'est interdit de
me faire des coups comme ça. Tu as des
tu as des situations euh tuas tu as une
circonstance atténuante.
Ouais. Et donc je dis d'accord, tu
parles de la première économie de
l'Europe qui permet en fait de tirer
tout le monde avec la France, le couple
franco-allemand, l'économie allemande
qui est une économie ultra spécialisée
hypergivore euh qui se retrouve en bisb
avec un stream qui a été pété, on sait
toujours pas par qui. On se retrouve
avec des pays de l'OTAN qui veulent
activer l'article 5 parce queil y a eu
des sabotages russes en Europe.
l'économie allemande sans énergie à bon
marché et ben ça va plus être une
économie allemande performante,
ça va être une économie allemande exang
là. Je sais pas si tu as vu les spots de
pub pour apprendre à se réchauffer dans
les appartements quand il fait froid. Et
on va où Éric ?
On on a on va on est dans une zone euh
tout à l'heure enfin euh tout à l'heure
j'ai comparer la situation avant 14.
D'accord. Donc inutile de te dire que je
je minore pas les dangers.
OK. Euh c'est moins qu'on puisse dire.
Et en plus je t'ai dit et et pour moi
c'est pas anecdotique, c'est pas quelque
chose d'en dessous. Il y a tous les
dangers climatiques. Quand je dis les
dangers climatiques, c'est pas juste le
réchauffement, c'est les phénomènes
cataclysmiques du fait de de
l'emballement du climat dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure pour la Miterranée, par
exemple, une fois par an, qui devient
bon. Donc je minore pas, donc c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire, je euh il y a
des moments où euh où je stresse quoi.
Enfin, je peux pas dire l'inverse. De la
tu fais tu nous fais de la solastalgie.
Non, je je milite et j'agis
politiquement. C'est peut-être ce qui me
permet justement de continuer à à faire
en sorte de garder une certaine dose
d'optimisme et d'essayer de bouger les
choses. Mais c'est ce que tu es vrai, ce
que tu dis est vrai. Mais je ne à part
abdiquer, moi je suis pas comme ça, je
suis bien militant. Voilà, je je suis
tout le temps militant. Bon, à part
abdiquer et puis dire bon bah finalement
euh c'est perdu pour perdu. Donc je
prends mes clics et mes claques, je me
barre en bateau 1. Enfants, tu as des
enfants ? Oui, j'ai des enfants, je me
barre en bateau et puis j'en ai assez
fait. Voilà, je suis pas fait comme ça.
Donc je vais me battre, continuer à me
battre pour faire en sorte que au moins
dans mon pays les choses bougent. que si
elle bouge dans mon pays, on peut
peut-être espérer, vu le poids de la
France, qu'elle bouge au moins dans
certains routes de pays européens via
des coopérations renforcées et que à
partir de là, on commence peut-être,
j'allais dire à essayer d'avoir avec
certaines parties du monde d'autres
rapports. Je veux dire, on n'est pas
toujours pied et point lié à avoir les
mêmes intérêts que le bloc occidental.
Je veux dire, on peut avoir des intérêts
avec les pays africains d'égal à égal.
On peut avoir des intérêts avec les pays
du Brix et cetera et cetera. Crois en
Dieu
non.
Au père Noël ?
Non. Tu
as pas d'amis imaginaire ?
Est-ce que je crois au Père Noël ? C'est
une bonne question. Non, j'y crois plus.
Non, j'ai j'ai J'y crois plus.
Je crois pas en Dieu. J'aimerais bien.
Ça aide.
Ça peut aider. Euh revenons, revenons à
nos 8 minutes qui nous restent. Est-ce
que tu as trois bouquins à conseiller à
notre communauté ? Tu vas revenir. Trois
bouquins à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Ouais, je vais aller sur les romans.
D'accord. Parce qu'il y a des bou Mais
je j'ai envie d'aller dessus.
Qui ont compté ? Qui ont compté pour
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Alors, il y en a il
y en a un, je suis désolé mais c'est
trois bouquins en un euh
Seigneur des Anneaux.
Non, pas du tout. Ça pourrait être ça.
Mais non, non. Euh non, je conseille de
lire Jules Valè
l'enfant le Bachelier, l'insurger. C'est
Jules Valè, c'est ce communeard,
rédacteur en chef du cri du peuple qui a
écrit "C'est parmi les plus beaux
bouquins du 19e siècle et moi ça m'a ça
m'a bien forgé la révolte."
Euh 100 ans de solitude de Garcia
Marquez, autre grand bouquin.
Euh
3e livre.
Écoute, je suis un peu embêté parce que
quand même le personnage
est devenu vraiment trop infréquentable
par son antisémitisme et euh
euh Céline voyage au bout de la nuit est
quand même quelque chose d'un point de
vue littéraire qui est quand même assez
prodigieux, qu'il faut avoir lu. Voilà.
Mais mais c'est toujours un peu
compliqué quand même euh plus les choses
se de faire la la part entre la l'œuvre
littéraire et puis la personne qui l'a
écrit. Euh voilà.
Avant de te poser la dernière question
euh de l'émission avant que tu reviennes
l'année prochaine en 2025, euh tu crois
que tu vas réussir à faire quelque chose
avec ta commission des finances ?
Euh oui oui, enfin en tout cas j'espère
j'espère déjà écoute, j'ai l'impression
que vu moi je suis un peu tu sais moi je
je comment dire euh je me déplace comme
tout le monde quoi, dans le métro tout
ça. Donc j'ai pas mal de contact avec
les gens. Quand les gens viennent dans
le métro ils me disent euh monsieur
Coquel faut tenir he sur les lettres de
plafond.
Quand je vais à la prison de ville
peinte pour supporter une association et
que des prisonniers me disent "Ah, quand
même avec leur 493, c'est insupportable,
je me dis que tout ce que je fais, il y
a quand même un côté pédagogique
d'éducation populaire qui sert pour
armer un peu plus les gens sur la
compréhension du du système néolibéral
de tout ça. Ça c'est une première chose.
Déjà, ça c'est pas mal. Voilà. Bon,
deuxièmement,
j'essaie aussi de m'en servir pour
arriver à en faire une bataille
politique et je te dis si il y a une
motion de censure comme j'espère voter
la semaine prochaine, euh ça sera ça
sera ça sera un des résultats.
On en profite pour dire à notre
communauté que c'est grâce à eux qu'on
arrive à faire Syerview sur leur tipi.
C'est eux notre indépendance, c'est eux
qui nous financent. C'est pour ça qu'on
peut faire des interviews fleuve fleuve
fleuve et réclamer Éric Clocrel pour
2025 pour finir cette interview. Éric
Cocrel, je voudrais savoir votre
conseil, ton conseil pour les jeunes
générations, une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable.
Jamais abdiqué, révolter.
Éric Cocrel, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]